[Applause]
all this week we've brought you american
history tv in prime time we wrap up this
week's coverage now with a look at the
life of robert smalls he was a south
carolina slave and ships pilot for the
confederacy and in 1862 commandeered the
css planter transport ship and
surrendered it to a federal ship that
action freed himself his family and 12
other slaves
robert smalls went on to become a
republican member of the u.s house this
is two hours
good afternoon
my name is joe darby i am pastor of mars
brown amy church it is my pleasure to
welcome you uh to this wonderful
celebration of an american hero i get to
do something tonight that pastor seldom
get to do i get to do the first part and
then i can sit down and shut up
let me present to you your moderator i'm
moderated as the great great grandson of
congressman robert smalls he's currently
the chairperson at glory foods
incorporated the national leader in
southern style see
seasoned food
he is an experienced executive with a
strong and dynamic career driving growth
and innovation at consumer marketing
companies michael leverages
world-class experience and thorough
leadership in brand strategy
and marketing management with the c
street general management and leadership
skill to offer unique blend of strategic
creative and management capabilities
he has earned an a b degree from the
maxwell school of government at syracuse
university and mba from the fuco school
of business at duke university he will
be the moderator for this panel
discussion tonight
and it is my pleasure to present to you
mr michael bouwer more
[Applause]
good evening
it has been a wonderful day here in
charleston
we started this morning at the
charleston museum
and
there were a couple of very
meaningful
unveilings on the harbor
and and we're capping the evening off
with a really rich and dynamic panel
that i'm really excited to uh to
introduce to you
we're going to have i'm going to
introduce the panel
and then really it's a dialogue and i'm
hoping that we can really generate some
conversation
among the group here
there's a microphone
to the left here that i hope you can see
to your right and uh
after the presentations i'll kick things
off with a question or two but please
feel free to come on up and you can sit
in the pew and relax until it's your
turn but
i'm really looking forward to
a very nice conversation with everyone
so our first presenter all the way over
on the left is dr bernard edward powers
jr he graduated [ __ ] laude from gustavus
adolphus college in saint peter
minnesota where he received the
bachelor's degree in history further
studies were undertaken at northwestern
university where he earned the ma and
phd degrees in american history dr
powers has in excess of 30 years in
higher education at malcolm x college he
served as behavioral sciences
curriculum coordinator and lecturer in
social science from 1977 to 78 from 78
to 92 he was employed at northeastern
illinois university where he served as
associate professor of history and
department chair
since 1992 he has been employed at the
college of charleston in charleston
south carolina as professor of history
teaching courses in the united states
and african-american history
he has been director of the masters
program in history and is presently
associate chairman of that department
professor powers has frequently given
speeches and presented numerous papers
at professional conferences on different
aspects of the african-american
experience he has served as a manuscript
referee for academic presses and has
reviewed books for several academic
journals including the journal of
american history the journal of southern
history the georgia historical quarterly
and the south carolina historical
magazine he's the author of black
charlestonians a social history
1822-1885
published by the university of arkansas
press in 1994. the book was selected by
choice magazine as one of the
outstanding academic books for 1995. he
also served as an associate editor of
the encyclopedia of south carolina
published in the fall of 2006. please
join me in welcoming dr powers
[Applause]
to his right
is dr
stephen r wise dr wise received his
bachelor's degree from wittenberg
university and a master's degree from
bowling green state university
he was drawn to the university of south
carolina to study under the direction of
the late thomas l connolly the noted
civil war historian under whom wise
earned his doctorate degree
dr wise has written and edited a number
of works and is currently working with
dr lawrence roland and dr gerhard
spieler on volumes two and three of the
history of beaufort county steven is the
director of the museum and the cultural
resource manager for the marine corps
recruit depot located at parris island
south carolina
stephen wise has been the featured
speaker on various south carolina
educational television productions as
well as on cunard and wind spirit cruise
liners additionally he has spoken on the
arts entertainment channel the history
channel and the discovery channel as
well as appeared in various south
carolina educational television
productions
he wrote the screen narrative for the
gilded age productions film american
iliad the siege of charleston a docu
film on the civil war in the charleston
area dr wise has received a number of
awards and is currently an adjunct
professor at the university of south
carolina beaufort dr wise will discuss
robert small's impact and legacy on the
civil war in the low country emphasis
will be on his service with the federal
army and navy his contributions to the
war effort and the reactions to his
activities within both the southern
white and slave communities please join
me in welcoming dr wise
to his right is dr w marvin delaney
dr delaney is the former executive
director of the avery research center at
the college of charleston currently he
is an associate professor and chair of
the history department at the university
of texas arlington he teaches american
history african-american history public
history
and the history of the american civil
rights movement in uta's undergraduate
and graduate history programs he is a
graduate of central state university in
wilberforce ohio where he earned his
bachelor of arts degree in history magna
[ __ ] laude he earned his master of arts
and doctor of philosophy degrees in
american and african american history at
ohio state university in columbus ohio
he has published several books including
black police in america
essays on the american civil rights
movement and born to serve he is
currently completing a book on african
americans in dallas a social and
political history for texas a m
university press
among his research interests are police
history criminal justice history and the
history of the american civil rights
movement he also combines the
traditional role of an academic
historian with that of a public
historian to assist community
organizations and museums in documenting
and preserving the african-american
experience please join me in welcoming
dr delaney
and last but of course not least is
elaine nichols a native of charlotte
north carolina and elaine nichols is
currently the senior curator of culture
at the smithsonian national museum of
african american history and culture
prior to beginning her work with the
nmaahc
she worked as a curator at the south
carolina state museum from 1989 until
2009. she's helping to develop an
inaugural exhibition that will be
included on the culture floor when the
museum opens in 2015.
the cultural expressions gallery will
focus on adornment religion and literary
and performing arts in 2005 she was
instrumental in collecting the robert
smalls parlor furniture for the museum
elaine has an m.a degree in public
service archaeology from the university
of south carolina and an m.a in social
administration and planning from case
western university
ms nichols is also a professional
storyteller please join me in welcoming
miss nichols
[Applause]
so we have a wonderful panel and
i'm excited to turn it over uh
to go ahead
thank you uh michael i'm so glad to uh
to be here
this evening with my distinguished
colleagues on this very auspicious
occasion
and let me start by just saying that the
name robert smalls of course became
legion in south carolina
and in many other places around the
country during the civil war
and after the civil war
robert smalls was a war hero
he would become a political leader with
national influence
his life was indeed the stuff of legend
the story is told
down in beaufort for example where
smalls was born that on one occasion two
african-american men were
walking down the road and they were
discussing
great men and what constituted great men
and who great men were and one man
asserted that robert smalls is probably
the greatest man on earth
the man was he was taught the man that
he was talking to said that smalls was
certainly great
but he wasn't the greatest man on earth
and indeed he knew someone even greater
and the first man asked the question
incredulously well who on earth could
possibly be greater than robert smalls
the second man
then offered jesus christ
as the greatest man that ever walked on
the earth
the first man was forced to concede
but he reminded man number two that
robert smalls was still young
now
i think that we should become familiar
with robert smalls for a variety of
different reasons
first
in his life
we can see most of the overarching
themes that african-american history
revolves around for example we see
slavery
emancipation
enfranchisement and political
empowerment
the nader and the rise of white
supremacy and finally
while smalls dies in 1915
some of the work that he did actually
laid the groundwork for
the second reconstruction
another term used to describe
the american civil rights movement
secondly
small's life is a consummately american
story
a story of triumph over adversity
success against the odds
and of course what better place to talk
about
such an american life than in charleston
small second home
and indeed a city unique in its
contributions to
americana
and the midwife
to many of those things that would
become afro-americana
now this evening i would like to talk
about the background to small's later
life
i want to talk about his experiences
in in
beaufort oh okay
in beaufort
but mainly in charleston as a way of
understanding
how these environments prepared him
for his later achievements in life
now robert smalls is born in 1839 in
beaufort he's the son of lydia polite
who was the slave of henry mckee
mckee was a planter
and mckee owned
approximately 60
different people who he used mainly in
the countryside
but lydia and robert comprised the main
part of his domestic labor force at his
beaufort home now
domestic service
had its positive aspects
and its disadvantages for example
domestics were on call around the clock
to attend to their to their owners
various needs
that obviously was a downside and a
negative
and then unlike field hands they had no
place to hide no place to get away from
their owners
and that proximity could be
discomforting to them and indeed it
could even be dangerous
on the other hand they were typically
clothed better than the field hands
and typically they were fed better than
the field hands also
domestics were also privy
to important information that might
prove essential and valuable
because of their proximity to their
owners and also to the people who came
and visited their owners
so domestics were frequently in a
privileged position
but henry mckee apparently was an
especially indulgent
slave master
he frequently had robert accompany him
in his carriage around town on horseback
to his various plantation properties
mckee taught smalls how to ride horses
to swim
to handle boats to hunt with a
gun and other kinds of things equally
significant
is the fact that henry mckee allowed
robert to remain with his mother
until he was almost
12 years old
and at that point his life would change
but in an unanticipated and crucial way
for his future
now before taking up this point
on the eve of
mother's day let me say something else
about lydia robert's mother
and i want to say two things firstly
she understood the extraordinary
privileges
her son
enjoyed but she wanted him to always
remember the routine and even casual
brutality that characterized the system
of slavery and experienced by so many
other people around them
and so for example on one occasion she
took him downtown to the jail
where slaves were being whipped
and she had him
look at these scenes
and these scenes
made a terribly important impression and
a deep impression
on robert smalls
lydia was indeed exposing him to what we
might call the politics of everyday life
and she was exposing him to the naked
power relationships that characterized
the system of slavery so that he would
always
keep those images present
in the forefront of his mind and
understand how
how blessed and how lucky he was
but secondly as i said his life would
change dramatically
in 1851 because
he was sent to work in charleston
now andrew billingsley a smalls
biographer
asserts that it was lydia robert's
mother that persuaded henry mckee
to send him to charleston
and she suggested this as a way of
perhaps protecting her son looking out
for him
thinking that he would probably do
better in a charleston environment
than had he been sent out to work
on one of mr mckee's plantations
and so in 1851 robert smalls does indeed
go to charleston and this was a
transformative experience
that shaped his adult fortunes because
slavery in the city was quite different
than slavery in the countryside
with an 1850 population of almost 43 000
charleston the state's major port was
really the big city
and in addition to the cosmopolitan
atmosphere of the city and the anonymity
of life in a major urban area
charleston's other
characteristics proved to be equally
significant
now for most of its history this city
like the state had a black majority
and in 1860 one third of all of the
states entire free black population
resided in charleston and so the
experience of seeing large numbers of
people
who looked like robert smalls and were
also free must have heightened his
aspirations for freedom
free blacks the elite particularly had a
highly developed organizational life
with voluntary associations with schools
mutual aid societies and organizations
for
intellectual improvement
now domestic service was an important
employment sector in charleston but
unlike on the plantations the city
afforded a much more diversified
occupational structure
which ensured
which ensured that
that free blacks and slaves would be
employed in a wide range of different
occupations some of which required
considerable skill
free black men were concentrated in the
building trades
and many free women practiced needle
craft trades in 1848 charleston slaves
were involved in at least 38 different
occupations
in addition to the foregoing examples
they worked
as blacksmiths as barrel makers in
brickyards rice mills
and for the railroad just to give you
some examples
and based on their skills and sometimes
their business
enterprises free blacks became property
owners
and sometimes very unusual situations
could arise for example those that owned
real estate sometimes rented their
homes and apartments to whites
and robert smalls probably knew of such
potentially subversive
relationships
now one of the hallmarks of urban
slavery was the hiring system in which
masters hired their slaves out to other
people
and slaves were sometimes allowed to
hire themselves out
seeking out their own jobs and
negotiating for wages
even though both of these things were
illegal
robert undoubtedly knew of this open
secret and probably participated in it
also
now while enslaved in charleston robert
smalls had many experiences that were
antithetical
to his status as a legal slave
while there he interacted with free
blacks
he even belonged to at least seven
different organizations
where methods were discussed in these
organizations for assisting slaves to
obtain their freedom
it was illegal for slaves to become
literate
but it was more difficult to enforce
this policy in the city because there
were signs all around there were
newspapers around books available and
all kinds of literary materials that
slaves had access
to
robert smalls undoubtedly interacted
with literate slaves
and these interactions again probably
further stimulated his passion for
literacy
now robert smalls must have learned
about charleston's revolutionary
heritage also
in the 1850s there were black and white
people in the area who were refugees
from the haitian revolution of the 1790s
and the early years of the 19th century
and others were familiar with stories
about this singular new world slave
insurrection which gave rise to a new
nation controlled by african people
closer to home
small surely knew about denmark vasey's
interactionary plans
how they unfolded in connection with
an effort to create an african methodist
church in the city
and the dire consequences of visey's
failure
more than anything else work shaped
robert small's life
he was employed in different jobs during
his first two years
in charleston for example as a lamp
lighter and as a waiter but he wanted to
work on the waterfront and this is where
he found his greatest opportunity for
employment and education
this indeed was the most cosmopolitan
part of the city also it must have been
exciting to witness the arrival
and the departure of ships and perhaps
interacting with
crew members from far away places and
smalls would begin as a wharf hand
loading and unloading ships
but he was able to move on to more
skilled and responsible positions over
time
he learned to rig the sails on ships he
became a sailor and eventually a pilot
making coastal voyages for his employer
as far south as northern florida
and during his travels smalls also
showed his own his own flair for
entrepreneurship
and he sometimes secured trade goods
from the places he visited brought them
back to charleston and then sold them
at a prophet
now robert eventually met hannah an
enslaved woman
they married in 1856
and had an extraordinary arrangement
with their owners
they lived in their own apartment
which was illegal
and the only way that they could could
have afforded this was for hannah
to hire herself out hire her time out
as a domestic which she did at the mills
house
and robert took on additional work
himself
now
if what i have described to you thus far
is not unusual enough the final
the final and the most surprising turn
of events
in what was clearly an extraordinary
life
was that robert made arrangements to
purchase his wife and children
from their owner
once they had owned once they had earned
the requisite monies
understand what i'm saying here
a slave
was making arrangements
to purchase
other slaves now
we don't know how this was to be
achieved
legally
we don't know that
but
hannah's
owner agreed to the arrangement
and it was indeed a singular arrangement
now the fact that robert and hannah were
allowed to do these things says much
about
their aspirations
it says much about their owners
and also about the place
where they lived
now the civil war began with the firing
on fort sumter
in charleston harbor
in april 1861
and those shots would usher in the next
phases of robert smalls biography
and the other panelists are going to
discuss those
themes and those phases with you now i
appreciate your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
well moving right along i'd like to uh
just a little amusing before i get into
talking about robert smalls and the
civil war very remarkable man obviously
as dr powers mentioned influenced by his
mother
he is going to be able to take advantage
of situations
and
for him you could say it's a little bit
of luck uh just happens to fall into the
right place with the right people
he is going to be able to
really expand upon
his position within
the low country within south carolina
and eventually within the nation
he is going to be part of at the start
of the civil war of a massive
workforce that that the confederacy
counted on to sustain their new nation
and its military this workforce made up
of free blacks but primarily made up of
slaves will do everything from grow
crops provide manual labor service
teamsters firemen stevedores and then
robert smalls case pilots of ships
of course the leaders of the confederacy
were very suspicious and wary of such a
workforce but they had to depend upon
them
but could never really trust them
when federal forces came near more often
than not the workforce would disappear
us as mentioned and as we all know
smalls is a very remarkable individual
but he also again will find himself in a
situation with some very special people
to help him along his way
during his time on the sea islands
when we look back and study what's going
on in the sea islands there are other
black leaders who you could argue at
least for a moment might rival robert
smalls individuals like prince rivers or
robert sutton these were ncos in the
first south carolina
but smalls will have more flexibility
will interact with more individuals and
will by the end and what we'll hear
about in reconstruction
come out as really the leader
of at least the low country and you
could very well argue the blacks within
south carolina
he was part as dr powers mentioned
working on the planter is going to be
part of a evolving maritime economy
that had been going on since the 1820s
though charlestonians don't like to hear
about this
beginning in the 1820s by 1830s and
1840s charleston is no longer a major
port
boston philadelphia and new york has
taken over the overseas trade charleston
is not that great of a harbor goods
supplies cotton primarily is shipped
from charleston up to boston new york
and philadelphia for shipment overseas
so you see the maritime trade along the
coast becoming more localized and has
become more localized again as dr powers
mentioned you see more slaves and free
blacks being used on these smaller
packets smaller steamships operating
along the coast
and robert smalls will be part of this
system that is created at this time
they are specially trained to work on
these packets
smalls himself will be referred to as a
wheel man
it was said that the term pilot could
only be reserved for whites so he was
called a wheel man instead of a pilot
at the start of the civil war the vessel
he's working on the planter will be
hired by her owner to the confederate
government
she will operate along the coast after
the firing on fort sumter
she will be found anywhere between
really jacksonville florida all the way
up to charleston sometimes going up to
georgetown carrying supplies for the
confederate military
he'll be part of the planters crew when
they destroy the lighthouse at hunting
island to sort of wipe out the
navigational aids for any union vessels
off the coast
shortly after the firing on fort sumter
abraham lincoln will declare a blockade
of the southern coast
to stop the importation of especially
military goods from europe and to stop
the exportation of cotton which then
could be used to buy military goods in
europe
the blockade was directed against
southern ports and charleston will be
one of these ports of course that will
find union warships beginning quite soon
after the firing of fort sumter
off the harbor trying to stop any type
of maritime trade
the problem was as we begin with the
civil war is to have an effective
blockade you have to use steam warships
and if you have steam warships you need
to have places where these vessels can
find coal you need coaling stations
so in order to create a stronger
blockade the north will have to begin
seizing harbors along the confederate
coastline and establishing naval depots
naval bases naval installations and on
november 7th 1861 flag officer samuel
francis dupont with a squadron of 17
vessels believe it or not the largest
fleet ever organized by the united
states up to this time
will seize port royal sound and in a
short time the navy will establish a
base in port royal sound and the army
will establish
a expeditionary force operating out of
hilton head island
when the federals defeated the
confederate forces guarding port royal
sound they not only will drive away the
confederate army
but also the vast majority of the
landowners and the planters within the
sea islands
they will come ashore and find
themselves in control of some 8 000
masterless slaves
though not initially prepared to deal
with these abandoned slaves the united
states will eventually establish a
program designed to employ educate and
recruit into the army the region's
former slaves by the spring of 1861 the
north had in place at port royal a very
ambitious program operated by
northerners who oversaw the growing of
cotton and the running of schools
there are a number of individuals
involved in establishing what becomes or
what is going to be termed the port
royal experiment
some of these individuals will play a
very important role in the robert small
story i mentioned samuel francis dupont
we'll get back to him in a minute
another important individual will be
mansfield french
he'll be a key player in the robert
smalls story he was a noted educator and
abolitionist the 51 year old french had
been among the founders of the port
royal experiment and he made sure that
women were part of the movement as well
another major player will be david
hunter the 59 year old west point
graduate one of the leading abolitionist
generals of the united states army
hunter was in command of the forces the
army forces that occupied the sea
alliance and in march of 1862
he received a directive from the war
department to raise a black regiment
which he started to do but he had
problems he found that a lot of the
former slaves really weren't that
interested in joining this regiment so
he thought he needed to give them
something to fight for so he will issue
on may 9 1862 a general order freeing
the slaves within his area of command
the states of georgia south carolina and
florida now as far as we know this
general order did not
influence robert smalls it's fairly
quickly turned over by
president lincoln
but we do not believe that smalls may or
may have heard of it but he had already
was making plans to escape from
charleston
smalls again is part of this massive
slave workforce that supported the
confederate military in and around
charleston both slaves and free blacks
you could argue were caught between two
fires
they worked willingly unwillingly for
the south free black served as volunteer
firemen some served as stokers on board
confederate warships slaves built
fortifications served as teamsters
carried ammunition and commissary
supplies others manned army and navy
support vessels essential in its
transporting material around charleston
harbor
confederate authorities knew that in
order to defend charleston they had to
depend upon this workforce
now the confederacy was having a hard
time defending this large
coastline
and they were finding also the federal
navy could easily come
in behind these islands cut off and
capture their forts and their batteries
so they begin shortly after the fall of
port royal withdrawing
fortifications troops artillery from
these exposed islands and bringing them
back around charleston
and smalls on board the planet will be
part
of this mission that's taking apart
confederate batteries fortifications
bringing the goods back to charleston
one of these fortifications that's being
abandoned is a confederate fort on
kohl's island
at the mouth of the stone river and in
fact it smalls and the planter will be
going out there nearly daily bringing
supplies back to charleston including
the artillery from the works on kohl's
island
at the same time because there were
federal forces off of charleston
there are a number
of slaves escaping from charleston in
boats going out to the blockading
squadron
shortly before smalls
carries out his mission on the planter
escaping on the planter
the crew of the confederate general in
command of charleston roswell ripley the
crew of his private barge will row out
and turn themselves over to the federal
fleet which just makes it even tougher
if you stop and think about it for
smalls to try to escape because the
confederates now are watching more
closely what's going on in charleston
but they hadn't reckoned with the
determination of robert smalls he's
going to make his plan i'm not going to
go into great detail up to the escape
but on the night of may 12th uh while
the vessel's white officers against
standing orders went ashore for the
night smalls and compatriots went to
work at 4am on may 13th with boiler
stokes steam raised the palmetto and
confederate flags hoisted the crew
that went along with smalls not all of
the crew did it could be anywhere from
five to seven members slipped the
moorings and smalls guided the vessel
from her wharf on the cooper river
across from the confederate headquarters
to a neighboring war for the steamer
edwalde emerging from the ottawa came
small as his wife daughter elizabeth
lydia and son robert jr the wife and
sister of one of the planters crewmen
and a slave sailor from the etowah and
another lady and a child
while wearing the captain's coat and
straw hat small steered the planter past
excessive lines of forts as he neared
fort sumter he blew the vessel steam
whistle and was allowed to pass once
beyond canon range smalls hauled down to
southern flags and hoisted a white flag
towel sheet
that his wife had brought along
in the morning mist small steamed a
planter toward the union warships came
alongside of the vessel onward the
onward was preparing for action clearing
their deck readying her guns as the
planter came alongside the captain of
the onward reported that passengers
emerged from the deck dancing singing
whistling
and some face towards sumter and utter
curses
and smalls removing the straw hat called
the captain of the onward good morning
sir i brought you some of old united
states gun sir
some union sailors are placed upon the
planner and smalls guided her to
beaufort
they've come out into this port royal
sound she is brought up to
alongside of admiral dupont's flagship
the wabash
the union officer makes his report than
dupont sends for smalls and he was very
impressed with smalls he called him
robert always called him robert said he
was very pleasant looking
trimmed fine teeth a clean and nice
linen check coat with a very fine linen
shirt having a handsome ruffle on the
breasts possibly part of the wardrobe of
the navy officer who commanded the boat
but fitting him very well if they were
i asked him a few questions to check the
narrative when he first took the notion
and what made him think he would be
successful
he had been thinking of it for about a
week or two the boat was taken in the
evening to her usual wharf where general
ripley's house and office are a steamer
was on each side of him he got his wife
on board quietly and the crew were of
one accord to try it then steam was got
up at four they let go their fasts and
stood down quietly on reaching the forts
of daylight with palmetto and
confederate flags flying when he came up
with the fort successfully he blew two
long whistles and a short to salute
customary and passing the forts this was
not only cute but intelligent and trying
to sneak by
they closely bonded if you can imagine
this the aristocrat dupont and the now
former slave robert smalls
besides bringing out a valuable steamer
robert smalls also had information
concerning confederate fortifications
defenses around charleston most
important was the news that the
confederates were evacuating the forts
at the mouth of the stone oh river this
was a very important passageway it's
what the british followed up the
stonewall river to capture charleston
during the revolution dupont quickly
ordered his commander off charles to
investigate
confirmed what smalls had reported and
on may 20th a week after smalls escape
union vessels will enter the stonehole
interestingly enough the commander of
these vessels that went into the stone
was percival drayton a south carolinian
the move into the stoner river will
result in an eventual attack by u.s army
forces against confederate lines on
james island they will be defeated
the army will evacuate but the navy will
keep up a presence in the stoner river
throughout the war
in the meantime smalls will be caught up
in other events related to activities at
port royal
besides the military
actions that are going on there's going
to be this sort of the start of
reconstruction and i'm not going to go a
great deal into this because i know dr
delany will talk about some of this
but
part of this is going to involve smalls
during the war
and what will be brought up a number of
times is taking smalls to the north
mansfield french one wanted dupont and
general hunter to allow smalls to go
with them to the north for a number of
reasons to help raise you might say
public knowledge
of what is occurring in the sea islands
to show to them that slaves could be
part of this military force fighting the
confederacy he said smalls is the
perfect example of this at first dupont
was a very wary of this he sort of
suggested well if you're going to do
this manfield's french you might as well
just turn robert over to barnum and let
barnum put him on display
but later dupont sort of came around he
said well i understand this that french
wanted a moral impression produced in
favor of the blacks among those people
who believe them and capable of any
capacity saying the officers at beaufort
many of them had confessed a change of
opinion once they met robert
now at the same time dupont right then
could not spare him smalls will be used
on a number of federal warships along
the southeastern coast
he also thanks to dupont smalls and the
other members the male members of the
vessel coming out the planter will
receive prize money
prize money is something that if a
federal warship would capture an enemy
vessel or a blockade runner that ship
would be taken to what's called a prize
court you would figure out how much the
ship is worth how much his cargo is
worth then the value of the ship and the
cargo would be divided among the
sailors who captured that ship
now as civilians
smalls and the other former slaves were
not technically eligible for this
dupont wrote the secretary of navy
suggesting that smalls be given this
prize money and his other the others
companions be given this prize money and
congress will
make the prize money available to them
smalls used his share to start a
business in beaufort and eventually
purchase the home of his former master
now another key player will arrive in
beaufort about this time though he had
been there earlier this is going to be a
fellow named general rufus saxton a west
point trained officer saxon was placed
over the port royal experiment and he
will work closely with mansfield french
with robert smalls and others
to carry out this sort of rehearsal for
reconstruction and the raising of black
troops at port royal
in august of 1862 saxon dispatched
french and smalls to washington d.c
they met with secretary of war stanton
was secretary of treasury chase and with
abraham lincoln
smalls fame had preceded them and at
each stop the pilot of the planter had
to retell his story of his escape from
charleston they proved to be very
effective ambassadors and before the
month was out they returned to port
royal with a directive for general saxon
to begin raising 5 000 black soldiers
from the region's former slaves
while gone the planter was transferred
to the army the planter was a
wood-burning vessel and the navy
primarily used coal
this didn't work logistically so they
would transfer the planter over to the
army
a month later in september saxon smalls
and french returned to the north while
saxon was on his way to washington dc
french was escorting smalls and his
family to new york for an extended tour
to raise money and interest in the port
royal experiment
again dupont was very worried about this
and he wrote his wife i took for granted
that robert smalls wanted to go but he
came to know if he and he came to know
if he was going to lose his place here
as pi as pilot for my vessels
and i confirmed to him that you are the
most superior negro i have ever met and
of course you will stay as my pilot
i told him you need not go to the north
unless you wish it that mr french was a
friend of him and his race and saw
advantages to him personally i told him
if you return in a month i would take
him on again as a pilot he said he would
then go with mr french and unless the
latter promised to have him back in
three weeks he would not go i then gave
him good advice as to the course of
which i said robert you have seen how
the navy officers have treated you they
have made no fuss about you given you
work and are kind in their feelings and
if you remain as you are now i and don't
get spoiled by the abolitionists they
will always be your friends
the reply was very striking admiral
that's the very point it is because i
know this that i have come to see you
today my best friends are in the navy
and on board this ship
though dupont was quite pleased of this
he was very worried uh smalls would be
in the north for longer than three weeks
which worried dupont he did return and
one of dupont's top assistants saw
smalls on the street in beaufort and
asked him you know robert has your head
been turned when you're up in new york
and he said the reply was it was turned
but it was turned but one way all the
time i was in the north toward port
royal
smalls will join the naval expedition
that's fitted out to attack charleston
in april of 1863. smalls will be the
pilot on board the keokuk the keokuk
looked like a monitor she was not a
monitor she was an ironclad very light
drafted very lightly armored she was had
the lightest draft
so her captain directed smalls to take
the keokuk as close as possible to fort
sumter for 30 minutes the thinly armored
vessel came under intense fire she was
struck 90 times
119 pound boat crashed into her pilot
house this is where robert smalls would
have been
and 19 shots pierced her at and below
the water line before smalls received
orders to take her out of battle
that night the keokuk was in sinking
condition
to defeat the dismayed robert smalls who
cried to think of being so near and yet
obliged to give up the fight the next
day the keokuk will sink off morris
island's southern end
in the aftermath of the battle
dupot who was the loser of this battle
will be replaced
and smalls will be transferred over to
the army to serve on board the army's
vessels we don't realize this but during
the civil war the largest navy in the
world
was operated by the united states army
7 000 vessels
robert smalls will be the army's duty
pilot along the southeastern coast
uh they're going to be part of the
movement that will be
prepared to launch the attack against
charleston in july of 1863.
the planner smalls
serving on board the planner as her
pilot will carry
troops will carry supplies back and
forth between port royal and morris and
folly island after the campaign in
november of 1863 the planner was
operating outside of charleston harbor
off folly island near the mouth of the
stone or river when the department's
chief quartermaster lieutenant colonel
alwa elwell directed the captain of the
planner to take his vessel into an area
where she would could come under enemy
fire the captain refused the order so
elwell immediately ordered his removal
and set directions to his chief
assistant at folly in morris island
stating sir you will please place robert
smalls in charge of the united states
transport planter as captain
he brought her out of charleston harbor
more than a year ago running under the
guns of sumter moultrie and the other
defenses of that stronghold he is an
excellent pilot of undoubted bravery and
in every respect worthy of the position
this is due him as a proper recognition
of his heroism and services the present
captain is a coward though a white man
dismiss him therefore and give the
steamer to brave black saxton
general gilmore the department commander
immediately approved elwell's order the
advancement will obviously add luster to
smalls's career
from this point on until the end of the
war smalls will serve as captain of the
planner working
for what would be about a hundred and
fifty dollars a month in today's money
that would be about three to four
thousand dollars a month
not bad pay today very good pay then
and uh he'll be part of the movement
into florida in june of 1864 uh smalls
will have his first taste and he might
say that in politics at a meeting in
beaufort he was selected by the union
people of south carolina to represent
them at the national convention of the
union party the coalition of republicans
and democrats who backed the lincoln
government
smalls was one of four blacks in a
16-person delegation
however he will not attend the
conference uh the army will direct him
to take the planter to philadelphia
for refitting so he does not actually
i'm sorry so he will not actually go to
baltimore
to be at the convention
but the other delegates did and some
consider them to be the first integrated
delegation ever sent to a national party
convention
they will be seated at baltimore but
since they did not come from a
recognized federal state they will not
be allowed to vote but it does give a
little bit of a forewarning of political
events in the low country especially
beaufort county when work was finished
on the planters falls and the vessel
returned to port royal be part of the
final great military campaigns of the
region he will be there when general
william tecumseh sherman's forces reach
savannah he will help transport supplies
to sherman's army refit sherman's army
he will help transport half of sherman's
forces to the town of beaufort so they
could prepare for the march into the
interior of south carolina
they will be the smalls will be part of
moving people up to
the city of charleston after charleston
is captured he will be there when the
flags are
again risen over fort sumter
and i just want to sort of end with this
little comment this is a description of
robert smalls when they raised the flags
over fort sumter on april 14th 1865
smalls on the planter are in the harbor
and this is as a participant wrote about
uh this that uh he saw the planner he
saw robert smalls
the paddle wheeler was crowded almost a
suffocation upon her three decks with
friedman who hung over the gunnels
mounted on the post doubled up in
deferred of corners peering through the
gangways darkening the wheelhouse upon
the top of which robert smalls a prince
among them self-possessed prompt and
proud giving his orders to the helmsman
in ringing tones of command
robert smalls and the planner will be
part of the friedman's
bureau's work along the coast uh he will
take the planter to baltimore where she
is sold and eventually both smalls and
the planter will return to south
carolina the planner will continue on as
a transport along the coast and robert
smalls will then you might say start the
next phase of his career
[Applause]
okay i guess that's my cue
robert smalls
obviously had a tremendous career
made a very significant impact on on
this country and left us a a large uh
legacy
uh i can just sort of recite some of the
things that he did but even that
wouldn't even touch um
in any way the the fullness and the
breadth of his impact
on late 19th century
america again most of us know he served
five terms in congress
uh he he served in the south carolina
senate he served in the south carolina
house and of course he he was the
collector of customs at for the port of
buford
but
beyond those things
uh he provides us
sort of an understanding and and a way
of reinterpreting reconstruction
a a way of reinterpreting the the civil
rights movement
now
so he sort of brings together those
those two fields you heard dr powers
allude to
his uh
being sort of the precursor to the
second reconstruction
because of what he did in the 19th
century
well let me let me start this way by
talking about
reconstruction
and robert smalls's role role in it and
you'll see how these two things come
together in terms of how he has
influenced american historiography
in 1909 w.e.b du bois
spoke before the american historical
association in new york city
he did a presentation called
reconstruction and its benefits
and
this uh this essay or this presentation
was actually published a year later in
in 1910 in the american historical
review
in it he offered uh one of the first
revisionist interpretations of of
reconstruction
now the general
consensus in in 1909 early 20th century
in fact almost up up to the 1960s was
that reconstruction was one of the worst
periods
in the history of this country
that reconstruction was characterized by
corrupt
carpetbaggers
and scallywags
and ignorant negroes
who misruled the south
who stole money who lined their pockets
and basically misgoverned
this the south
the the idea was and as one historian
put it was that
by allowing african-americans like
robert smalls to participate in
government
barbarism have been put in place over
civilization
well du bois
countered that interpretation in fact
challenged it thoroughly
he outlined that
the
so-called ignorant negroes who had
served in the governments in the south
during this period had made three very
important contributions
they had
brought about the first democratic
governments in the south
they had established the first free
public schools
and they had passed new social
legislation
and as many of you know robert smalls
did all three of those things
and of course
as one of those so-called ignorant
negroes
he for example proposed the
the
legislation to create south carolina's
public schools
he proposed several civil rights bills
and i'll go go through those with you
and indeed he tried to bring about
democracy
in south carolina for the first time in
the history of the of this state
robert smalls
was especially
interested in dealing with civil rights
in south carolina now you heard my
colleague steve talk about his big in
philadelphia in july of 1864. we had an
interesting incident uh occurred to him
in in philadelphia
as he was taking
as he was taking uh the planter
to this the philadelphia shipyard to to
be repaired he tried to catch the
streetcar
to
to the shipyard
and he had a white sailor were actually
ejected from the from the streetcar
that is they did not allow african
americans in philadelphia to ride the
the streetcars in 1864.
this had a tremendous impact on on
smalls
in addition had a tremendous impact on
this on the city of philadelphia
african americans have been trying for
several years to to gain access to riot
to riding the streetcars in philadelphia
but it took smalls and his
his notoriety
his his fame
to actually make it actually make it
happen that is
uh the the word spread and hit the
newspapers that here's a civil war hero
who cannot ride the streetcars
in philadelphia so
it prompted a boycott of the of the
streetcars by even some whites in
philadelphia which then eventually led
to african americans gaining the right
to use to ride the streetcars in
philadelphia in 1867.
smalls as you know was part of the
constitutional convention that took
place here in south carolina in 1868 and
as i said he proposed the legislation to
create the state's free public school
system
then
he also
helped to pass a a law that brought
south carolina
in line with the civil rights bill that
the u.s government had passed in 1866 of
course the civil rights act of 1866 was
was a measure
to get rid of the black codes and
basically to
enforce the the 13th amendment
while also serving in the state
legislature
smalls in 1869 and 1870 proposed the
state's first civil rights
legislation
and and this was a measure to to ensure
that african-american citizens
could use public accommodations in the
states with without um being
discriminated against and this measure
actually stayed in in the state
constitution until 1889 when it was
repealed
then in 1876 he did something else very
interesting
when the army
real and a bill to reorganize the army
was being considered by the house
he added an amendment
which said
that
if
that the army could not discriminate
against anyone
on the basis of race
and also that race should not be
considered when people of course joined
joined the army now small was definitely
ahead of his time because as we know
the army in the us military didn't just
didn't just desegregate until 1949
but here in in 1876 as i said smalls was
trying to
force the army to desegregate but
unfortunately
the
the amendment was voted down
in 1884 he proposed another amendment
this was a an amendment to license
liquor dealers in washington dc excuse
me a law to license liquor dealers in
washington d.c
and smalls added an amendment that
those who sold
liquor in washington dc could not
discriminate in the establishment
studies they had to be able they had to
sell it to everybody
and of course his
his purpose for doing that
was to open up restaurants and taverns
and to african americans so that they
could go to any to could use any public
accommodations that they wanted this
also of course was um
taken out of the
the law
now one of the things that smalls was
concerned with was the right to vote
in 1890
he wrote an article
in the north american review
called called election methods in the
south
and of course
in that article he castigated the state
of south carolina for its efforts or for
the
events and activities that had taken
place between 1876 and 1890 to
disfranchise african americans
he talked about the eight box law for
example
in this particular article this was the
the law where
african-american votes actually of
course voters in general but more
specifically african-americans had to
come and make sure
they had
eight different
ballot boxes you had to make sure that
you when you cast your vote that you put
your ballot in the right vote
box or it wouldn't count
he also of course castigated the state
of south carolina for allowing the klan
and the rifle the rifle clubs
in the upstate area the democratic rifle
clubs to sort of run rampant and to
shoot and kill african americans as they
tried to vote
he called on benjamin harrison who was
the president of president at that time
to enforce the law
to defend the the right to vote
in the state of south carolina and in
the south
in general were you trying to get my
attention oh
okay
so
small smalls then
gives us
an understanding then of
how the civil rights movement
that is in the in the goals of the
movement
extended back past 1954.
now we historians we
we argue back and forth over this issue
of when did the civil rights movement
begin or and and of course
uh there are those of us who believe
that the civil rights movement is is a
long movement
that i had one colleague say to me that
the civil rights movement started when
their first slave got off the boat
but then
most people though will say that it
started in 1954 with the brown decision
and the montgomery bus boycott
well the long civil rights movement
though actually does go back to people
like robert smalls
who indeed were
trying to
pass and propose
legislation that would give african
americans equal opportunity
to to work
equal opportunity and public
accommodations as you've heard
uh
equal access to to the ballot
and basically
dignity and smalls his own life sort of
sort of sets the tone for that in that
he was a a fighter
he he challenged discrimination
every opportunity and every chance that
he he got now some of you know as you
heard helen say this morning i worked
with
her family to develop the
exhibition that is now at the charleston
museum so i spent a year with robert
smalls you might say
that is
reading all of his works looking for his
pictures reading everything that i i
could about him and again as you've
heard this this man was a very unique
individual
in that
he put to lie
some of the beliefs about slavery in
this country some of the beliefs about
african-american talent and abilities in
this country
at a time
basically when most people felt
if you were black
you were inferior in facts balls had one
of his colleagues in the house tell him
that
and of course he challenged him on the
spot
so
um
robert smalls
as i said
has had a tremendous impact on the
historiography on reconstruction
and on the on the civil rights movement
and he has allowed us as historians to
use his life as an example and and to
challenge the nonsense about the
negroes to challenge the not the
nonsense about african americans being
made and wanting to be slaves
and loving their masters although i have
to say
smalls they try to bail out the mckees a
couple times
but again that doesn't mean that he
loved them in the way that
they said that slaves loved their
masters in the 19th century so with that
i'll i'll pass it on to
look ahead
[Applause]
good evening
i am delighted to be here with you and
to bring greetings to you from
our founding director lonnie g bunch at
the national museum of african american
history and culture and i've been asked
to talk about
robert smalls and the future and he
certainly does have a future with the
national museum of african-american of
his history and culture let me begin by
talking about the history and mission
of the museum
the national museum of african-american
history and culture was established
in 2003 uh 2003 as the 19th museum
of the smithsonian institution the
largest museum complex and research
organization in the world
its mission is to provide for the
collection study and establishment of
programs and exhibitions related to
african-american life
art history and culture
enacted through congressional
legislation this museum represents a
national initiative of profound cultural
importance that will impact this nation
for generations to come
the museum will bridge a major gap in
our national memory by creating
exhibitions and programs
focusing on a wide arc of history
slavery reconstruction the harlem
renaissance the great migrations to the
north and west
segregation civil rights
and beyond
it also will celebrate african-american
creativity and cultural expressions
through art dance theater and literature
the museum will be located on a 5 acre
site adjacent to the washington monument
on the national mall in washington d.c
home to the world's largest collection
of museums and at the center of one of
the most public spaces of the nation
scheduled to open in 2015 the museum
exists today
through a vast array of programs
nationwide
including special exhibitions
and online presence
and numerous educational programs and
workshops for youth and adults alike
the vision
in many ways there are few things as
powerful and as important as a people
as a nation that is steeped in its
history
often america is celebrated as a place
that forgets
this museum seeks to help all americans
remember
and by remembering this institution will
stimulate a dialogue about race
and help to foster a spirit of
reconciliation
and healing
there are four legs on which this museum
will stand
the first
is to create an opportunity for those
that care about african-american culture
to explore and revel in that history
second
equally important is the opportunity to
help all americans
see just how central african-american
history is to all of us
the museum will use african-american
history and culture as a lens into what
it means to be an american
additionally
the museum will use african american
culture
as a means to help all americans see how
their stories
their histories
and their cultures
are shaped and informed by international
considerations
and how the struggle of
african-americans has impacted freedom
struggles around the world
and finally
as a 21st century museum
the national museum of african american
history and culture
must be and will be
a place of collaboration
we must be a truly national museum that
reaches beyond washington to engage new
audiences and to collaborate with the
mired
of museums and educational institutions
both nationally and internationally
ultimately
the national museum of african american
history and culture
should be a place of meaning of memory
of reflection of laughter of hope
it should be a beacon that reminds us of
what we were
what challenges we still face
and point us toward what we can
become
the vision of the smithsonian's national
museum of african american history and
culture is to inspire learning
and understanding
promote healing
foster dialogue and reconciliation
in an environment that tells the
american story through the lens of
african-americans
in 2005
lonnie bunch was hired as the founding
director of the museum
the museum will present the
african-american story as part of the
fabric of american life a life of
freedom of bondage
of hope and resiliency
of struggle and pain
of successes and triumphs
it allows us to look at american history
from an african-american perspective
and by so doing we can see how important
african-american history is to a larger
american history
robert smalls
is included
in the museum's vision
and it includes the stories related to
robert smalls
and his life and word
in february of 20 february of this year
the
museum celebrated the groundbreaking
and
president obama was there and i want to
share with you his words in talking
about the importance and significance of
this museum
he said that moments like this
made him think about his daughters
sasha and malia
and what i want for them to take away
i want them to see how ordinary
americans can do extraordinary things
how men and women just like them
have the courage to right or wrong
he said i want them to appreciate this
museum
not just as a record of tragedy
but as a celebration of life
and when we look at again robert smalls
and the
is associated with his life
we think of those as some of the ones
that we've talked about my colleagues
have talked about previously
those that are related to the individual
and personal stories
his immediate circle and family and
friends
but there are also many other stories of
success and celebration that celebrated
beyond that
one of the most significant aspects of
his story focuses on him as a
self-determined man a man with a purpose
he is perhaps most remembered for
liberating his wife their children and
the other slaves by commandeering the
uss planter
but in addition there's a great deal of
national
notoriety that's associated with that
hero heroism
robert smalls also had again as my
colleagues have mentioned
a most enduring political career that
spanned more than 40 years
this was a significant feat
for a man who was born into slavery
and although a very shrewd and skilled
politician he was marginally literate
having taught himself to read
his personal achievements were symbolic
victories for millions of
african-americans
who despite severe limitations
redefined
and ultimately secured their future
in america
in other instances his story contains
long-lasting consequences that touch the
lives of many people across time and
space
as as dr delaney just mentioned the
compulsory public education system that
operates in south carolina today
owes its genesis to smalls and the
leaders of the reconstruction era
when he returned to beaufort
he purchased the mckee home on prince
street
the home was a symbol of his wealth and
power
a visible mark on the landscape that
informed both visitors and pastors by
that he had achieved a certain measure
of success
he was successful
not only as a politician but as a
businessman and a property owner
he owned and operated a store in
beaufort he also owned substantial a
substantial amount of property from 1866
to 1868 in beaufort and on the sea
islands
in 1870 his net worth in real property
was six thousand dollars and his
personal worth was estimated to be a
thousand dollars
smalls has been described
as quote good humored intelligent and
self-possessed end of quote
and as a financially independent
businessman such a characterization
would imply a person who entertained
many people in his home not only for
social reasons but for the purpose of
cultivating relationships with
influential leaders
that would have bolstered his financial
and or political success
using one's home to provide social
occasions to promote such interests
was and continues to be an effective way
to build and nurture important
associations
as a house slave
smalls would have observed just such
interactions
in the mckee home
during the post-war during post-war
south carolina
he helped to create a new america
a society
that changed america and his home and
the richly appointed furnishings
would have been part of the material
culture
that signaled his role and importance in
fashioning what he and others
hoped would be a permanent elevation of
african-americans
the significance of his home is
reflected in contemporary descriptions
of the wedding ceremony
that was held at first african baptist
church
in 1890.
the news in courier described the
wedding in relations to his home
quote
the residence of the groom was
brilliantly illuminated
and thither the bridal party with their
many friends repaired
and the celebrations of the nuptials was
concluded by an expensive and elegant
supper
the entire community extended to the
happy couple their warmest
congratulations
end of quote
the life and accomplishments of robert
smalls will be featured in two of the
history galleries and in different
exhibition formats
one will be slavery and freedom
and the other will be the period
that examines the era of segregation
that followed reconstruction
the museum has acquired
a number of pieces of furniture as you
heard mr moore mentioned previously from
the smalls family that was part of the
home on prince street
the furniture dates from the mid-1850s
to the late 1880s
if the furniture belonged to and was
used by smalls and his family
small's home was a showplace where he
observed the world
and the world observed him
it represented the height
of his career
and was and is
an appropriate material example for
illustrating the life of an important
political
and community leader in beaufort south
carolina during the late 19th century
the furniture reflects his success as a
political leader
and his success as a well-to-do
homeowner
even by today's standards the home and
its furnishings would be considered
impressive and part of a grand way of
life
visitors to the museum will have an
opportunity to examine the challenges
that the nation faced
during reconstruction as it grappled
with a major shift in the political
economical social
and demographical structure
that had formally defined african
americans as little more than beasts of
burdens
the exhibitions will tell many stories
stories of how formally enslaved
african-americans
transitioned to freedom
and stories of how a significant number
of african-americans such as robert
smalls assumed important leadership
roles
as they created an infrastructure for
supporting the family
community
church
educational institutions
businesses and civic and social
organizations
while the furniture will represent the
life that he created for himself and his
family in post-slavery beaufort south
carolina
he will also be featured in a media
production which tells the larger story
of the early period of reconstruction
and the important role that he played in
shaping and influencing the politics in
south carolina and the nation
there are plans to also include him
in the second exhibition called
defending freedom defining freedom
era of segregation 1876
to 1968.
and there are some well the furniture
will be used to capture the story of
smalls and broadly african americans as
they transition from a period of great
triumph and success during
reconstruction
to a period of codified
disenfranchisement
segregation humiliation and sometimes
violence
the many stories that we will tell at
this museum are stories about people
like robert smalls who are part and
parcel of american history
the national museum of african american
history and culture
will be a place where all can discover
recover
and appreciate that centrality
i hope that you will join us when the
museum opens in 2015.
thank you very much uh
let's please just give another warm
round of applause to our panelists
[Applause]
i'd like to shift a little bit uh to the
second half uh or so of the program
uh i'd like to start off with some
questions but i really encourage and and
hope that we can generate some real
activity and energy uh from you all as
well and as i mentioned uh for anyone
who has a question just please find your
way up to the front here and we'll we'll
get right to you i would also remind the
panelists about the microphones and as
we can keep those uh close to us
for me hearing this kind of
these kinds of stories these kinds of
talks are really
fascinating and illuminating in so many
different levels you know i'm very
intimate with the story as robert's
great great grandson i've heard about it
from my mother my grandmother aunts and
uncles
and i feel a real personal connection to
it but it's always
really almost amazing to me to learn
about my great great grandfather from
folks who have spent their professional
lives studying about him and so it's
it's uh it's always a great experience
for me
i'd like to ask the panel
one of the
consistent questions that i get every
time
that i
get up and talk about robert smalls is
if robert smalls he did all these
wonderful things these amazing things at
so many areas and aspects of his life
why is he his stature in this country
even though over the last maybe 10 years
it's certainly grown but why is he
relatively unknown i mean if you think
about all that he did you know i'd stack
his life and career up against
plenty of folks throughout american
history paul revere i mean you know many
folks what why do you think that uh
robert stature is relatively muted in
sort of the pantheon of american history
i'd like i'd answer the question by
again referring to the negative
interpretation of or the negative
historiography related to reconstruction
again
du bois
and others after him pointed out all the
things and all the accomplishments of
people like robert smalls
uh from 1865 to 1877 and all and and
thereafter
but
when
the democrats we took the south
they literally tried to wipe out all of
the history that had taken place wipe
out the stories about people like robert
smalls
and and create these myths
i see mr mordock in in the audience and
he wrote about this last week
how indeed south carolina in particular
had sort of rewritten this history to
write black people out of it in
particular and to write rebels and and
people who challenge the system like
robert smalls out of it and so so
we're recovering it we're reclaiming it
we're retelling it now
but we're
we're we're picking it up after i'd say
a good almost 100 years
where you know it was literally wiped
out of the history books
i would i would also
add that in the case of smalls and
people like robert smalls
really this first generation of african
political leadership i think one of the
basic assumptions that many people have
have made
in america is that their interests have
only been in promoting the interest of
of people that look like them and
that's absolutely incorrect robert
smalls and
and members of this first generation
of the black political leadership were
interested in promoting the economy the
economic development of south carolina
and other places where they where they
serve interested in you know promoting
public education
for everyone civil rights legislation
that would benefit everyone but there's
been this attempt to kind of narrowly
portray them
uh when they've not been portrayed as
being enabbed and corrupt and so on then
the pigeonholed them as merely being
quote unquote representatives of a black
people and and that's just absolutely
incorrect it's been a way of
marginalizing them i think
uh then just a little comment on that is
you could look at smalls as being
localized staying in south carolina
staying in the low country where if you
look at frederick douglass the speaking
tours to going to europe the great
amount of literature he wrote versus
what smalls really didn't produce much
writing at all
i think you see that smalls
keeps himself very much into the local
area and that as dr delany said then
when south carolina is redeemed you
begin to lose your knowledge of robert
smalls
i agree with my colleagues but i want to
take a different
perspective and say that
i think that robert smalls
is
the name at least is well recognized by
young people they might not know of all
of his accomplishments
but they would recognize the name very
much as they would recognize the name of
harriet tubman
so i i think that in many ways he has
been recognized again they might not
know all the details associated with him
uh
come come on up to the side
um
i would like to add a very small part
and
an attempt to
add to your question please
one of the unfortunate problems in terms
of history is that we don't have visual
identification of us as a people in most
cases
so in our school systems there are no
visual imagery
of
the great robert smalls and if you don't
have visual imagery in your schools and
in your churches then our children the
generations of children are just not
going to be familiar with the facial
imagery
now we speak about the literal
nature of robert smalls and indeed he
did not write much but when you look at
your church bibles
one of the most interesting aspects of a
church bible it certainly was when i was
a child
was the paintings in the bible that
illustrated the stories so if you don't
have visual imagery of african americans
also in the case of uh
our arts
the lacking in terms of supporting
visual artists
if the stories are not told and the
stories are not supported i.e
collections
and placed in institutions where our
youth have an opportunity
to visually connect with them
then many of these people will be
forgotten one of the most
illustrious period in our recent history
is that of the wpa period
when under the auspices of president
roosevelt and mrs roosevelt
it was perhaps the largest point in time
in america where
images of african americans were
displayed
throughout the country
after the closing of the wpa period
most of that work was ordered destroyed
because they did not want it on the
open-air market but unfortunately in the
destruction of the work we know
whom
the works were destroyed and that was
certainly mostly of african-american
people and women
thank you yeah thank you i'd also uh
introduce he didn't introduce himself
but this is jonathan green who's a
wonderful wonderful artist and
specializes in art
in the low country here yeah thank you
for that
i'm gonna i'm gonna get you in just one
second i want to
speed through just a couple of quick
questions and if you all could speed
your answers along with me that would be
great
um dr powers you talked about some
unusual
kinds of things about robert smalls life
the fact that he and his wife lived in
an apartment that he was negotiating
her purchase
as it was um it seemed like
if you think broadly about robert's life
that there were a number of instances
where sort of lightning was striking the
relationship that he had with his master
the relationship that he was able to
have with his mother the fact that he
was able to live kind of on his own
uh
you know in charleston
the fact that he was able to pull off
this vision to
commandeer the planter you know a number
of kinds of things um
are there any thoughts about
why and how he
i mean he was able to
come about these sort of unusual kinds
of things that certainly supported and
aided him in
his achievements
well uh i guess you'd have to i guess
you'd have to say either a charmed life
or probably a blessed life
he was uh he was certainly raised to be
a religious
uh young man and and and so far as i
know continue to be
uh very religious in his in his in his
life and so i think where he to explain
it himself he would say
that the hand of of god was upon him
directing his his fortunes and opening
up really
a way for him uh
to prosper
to to achieve to become self-actualized
but also uh robert smalls as
as we all know was was a man of of great
vision
of great vision and
[Music]
he understood
that the direction that his life was
moving in was charting a course
for whole people
and
he had to have seen himself
as a man
of destiny not in an egotistical way
because because i don't have that image
of him at all
but as a person who
through
sharing his experiences sharing his
achievements
or working toward
his own self-actualization
and benefit benefiting his family
he saw himself as kind of setting an
example you know the kind of example
that we say that we that we need so much
more of today he was that example and he
understood himself acting in that way
and and and i think
he would probably also say that um
that just kind of based on the life that
he was leading he continued to be
blessed
uh sir do you have a question
good evening my name is irving fordham
and i commend you for
my name's irving fordham and i'd like to
commend you for your your comments
i'd like to make a brief comment and
pose this question
the commentator in the theme is
errors of inclusion
if you think about
if you think about these
if you think about these
national
international incidents
the trayvon martin situation
the situation in the arab uprising like
syria and libya you'll have an american
politician who talked about we're a
nation of laws
and want to lecture other countries
about democracy
then you had the situation with the
latino community passing laws in the
state of arizona
other southern southern
states following arizona
leadership
and americans are oblivious ignorant to
know that like in south carolina
after denmark vici
we had badges
to
stifle
the friedman
my question directed to you
history is your passion
most americans
they might be fixated on nba finals
this year i tutored
young african-american boys
basic literacy
mathematics skills so regardless of
gender ethnicity
what you do is extremely important to
the contribution united states of
america
you're our community leaders
we need you on this national platform of
c
c span
to speak to our countrymen
the value of history
and i i would just end by saying this
ten years ago
i was working
in north adams massachusetts
i had an apartment in east greenbush new
york commuting to work
i stopped
at a grocery store
and then to check out
there was this this laminated one pager
on american history
1822
revolt in charleston south carolina now
most people in this arctic audience who
are native charlestonians
you can get an a
in south carolina history
and be
totally ignorant about denmark vc
and the gentleman you're profiling
tonight
once again appreciate
all the work you do on behalf of us but
but you could each you
just speak generally and let me give you
one example because two weeks ago i was
watching c-span
these words are not synonymous
your peers will talk about southern
history
and if you get up and publicly
project that you're an expert
you're an authority about a subject
and all you can speak about
is the secessionist
that's cause you are ignorant and you
didn't do not you personally but your
peers didn't do this their work on
alternative viewpoints
and as you go across south carolina you
see a dearth
of information about the native
americans
and we as african-americans we are not
invisible people brother can you form
your question
refreshing question this is some
feedback in college on the importance of
history that we need to know our history
you want to take a stab yes yes yes
thank you very much for your for your
observations i think one one way to link
what we're talking about here tonight to
the gentleman's question is
this this time period in american
history that we have focused on through
the life of robert smalls
the period of of slavery the civil war
and reconstruction
is a
part of a process
by which in through which the nation has
become
not perfect but more perfect
over time in other words
american democracy has has many flaws
we're aware of that
but nevertheless the onward march of
history has shown
america to become a better nation over
time a more inclusive nation over time
we're not where we need to be but thank
goodness we're not where we have been
and guess what one of the reasons we
have been able to make the kind of
progress that we have made
has been through
the liberation of african americans from
slavery to emancipation to freedom
13th amendment 14th amendment 15th
amendment and so on and so forth civil
rights movement
ultimately we get the anti-war movement
the women's rights movement
and so on and so forth were all a part
of
not becoming perfect but a more perfect
nation and that's what that's the
direction that we need to continue to
move in
i think you are correct in that
sometimes we can't see the forest for
the trees
uh we do get involved in our own topics
and
don't really understand why other people
aren't as interested or can find the
same
answers that we do find i do believe in
the last 20 years there's been a
wonderful movement with the park service
in both south carolina and in the nation
uh to put forward i i do teach south
carolina history at the university of
south carolina beaufort and i think dr
edgar's history of south carolina covers
all things very well the encyclopedia in
south carolina the information is there
we just need to get it out to the people
to see and it is part of our jobs as
historians to do that
and i would excuse me ad that we have to
keep in mind that
learning
occurs in many of our environments not
just the formal uh structures that we
think of in terms of the schools and um
but it occurs in places like this
institution where we're sitting here the
churches uh within the community
and so i think if our young people
aren't informed
um we have to all assume responsibility
for it and it's something that we have
to continue to do it's not a lesson it's
like a
good story that you tell
it gets better every time you tell it
and so we have to continue to do that in
many different places and assume
responsibility for it
do we have others lining up for
questions or
i'm gonna just come on up to the front
here and uh and you can get in line and
uh i just have a quick question you know
part of the challenge of history is
helping young people kind of understand
contextualizing
who someone was that may have been
around 150 years ago or whatever i i've
heard i'm sure all of you have heard
some people have said that our current
president and first lady remind some
people of the kennedys in terms of
charisma and things like that
are there any
20th century examples of people through
in history that robert smalls might
uh
that there might be some sort of a
connection to help give maybe some
younger people
um
a sense of the kind the role or the
stature or the accomplishments maybe
that robert smalls
had does anything come to mind
i know that's a
that's a trick one
but keep that in mind
maybe we'll get to it later sir
um
my name is gus augustus holt um
i am the historian for the 1955 cannon
street all-star baseball team
which uh
is related to
what you just alluded to as far as
why
stories are not known
as well as others and and why
uh our history per se and the history of
robert smalls and those
others like him who was pioneers who
helped shape
the fabric of america
who actually built
america now
uh there's a saying that goes like
the pan
is mightier than the sword
well the african-american community as a
whole
did not control
the pan
and the
media
basically enhances
what
they feel
is relevant
and
what they feel empowers them
the media and and and not only the media
but the uh
our educational system was not concerned
about
enlighting
and empowering african americans
so
it was our job as parents
and through our various
uh institution
uh
the church
our faith-based institution that's how
we
educate ourselves to the history
of
our people of the african-american
contribution
to america
question
but let me say this question is though
and my question is
really
uh
to this panel this is steam panel i i
must add
uh because i know
these gentlemen
they have and i don't have a question
per se but
these gentlemen
have
contributed
greatly
to the education and the enlightenment
to the contribution
of african-american
especially in in
relating to the avery institute
and dr delany dr powers
uh miss nichols
they have contributed a lot
and but it's up to us to challenge
the
educational institutions
in the school system
to really
push
the information out to our kids
and i appreciate you because i really
appreciate this panel and for what
they're doing now
thank you very much thank you
i have a question for you miss nichols
um
we were
this morning at the charleston museum
which i guess is the oldest museum in
the country
you are at the largest museum in the
world i guess
um people of african descent have been
in this country since 1619
what what happened what was sort of the
politics or what happened that is
bringing
the new museum of african-american
history to life at this time
well actually it was earlier than that
where african-american civil war
veterans were calling for this kind of
commemoration
we had the leadership of someone like
john lewis who really pushed for
this national african-american museum
and its time has come
and african americans need to be
represented in these kinds of cultural
institutions so
you have questions sir
i might add on that that a major part of
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
was the establishment of african
american studies which was to make it
possible for african americans to review
their own history
write their own history and develop an
understanding of their experience so
ancient questions like who are we
identity
could be resolved more
matter-of-factly
my question relates to robert smalls
unfinished work
the unfinished work of robert smalls
what what did smalls not complete
we see the fort royal experiment
the attempts to
set up an economic environment in which
the former slave would be able to
support himself raise a family
start businesses
normally develop as any people would
this is wrecked by the
the democratic uh party and and the
aftermath of the beginning of the first
reconstruction uh and and the sec and
after the second reconstruction which
was black reconstruction as du bois
defines it
uh what do you see uh
us doing today
with regard to this unfinished work of
economic development the economic
empowerment of these people who for
centuries have been
uh
exploited and and and robbed by the
system in america
uh well part of robert smalls's work
will be involved on the sea islands and
the establishment of a black yulmendri
on the sea island the ownership of land
the working conditions on the sea
islands a lot of people don't realize
this but the sea islands were a boom
area after the civil war
good industries good jobs good wages
plus numerous farms that were gained by
the former slaves on the sea island
and what destroys them
will be in many ways or really greatly
diminish this will be the depression in
the 1920s
where actually they'll go down to wages
will drop to 20 cents a day
in the 1920s the sea islands around port
royal had a population of 40 000 people
by 1940 it's down to 20 000 because
people have to leave the area to find
new jobs and such
he set up a legacy in the sea islands
which does last well into the 20th
century and then conditions
economic conditions will completely
change the area
one of his greatest legacies though will
be where i work on paris island
while he was a member of the south
carolina legislature he pushes for a
naval station at port royal when he
becomes a u.s congressman he
puts petitions before the u.s congress
for the establishment of a naval station
at port royal and in the 1880s the
united states navy will establish on
paris island the port royal naval
station this naval station is eventually
moved to charleston
but it becomes now the home of the
marine corps recruit depot where i work
and just put a quick plug in for our
museum please come down and visit us and
also come and visit penn center out on
the sea islands as well where it sort of
you can follow more of the story of
robert smalls
i would say that
one of the things that robert smalls
didn't complete was indeed
even though even though for a short
period he did have this power base his
political power base uh he wasn't able
to maintain it and again
not through any fault of his his own but
because of the the forces of the
democratic party the in the ku klux klan
and the the
democratic rifle clubs
and he essentially was trying to do
what other american ethnic groups had
had done in in this country in terms of
using political using politics using
political power to build an an economic
base and again we we see it in the 19th
century and early 20th century over and
over again among the irish
uh among the italians
of how they use politics to help the
their groups to to build economic power
and
he was thwart thwarted just as most
african-americans in the late 19th and
at the turn of the 20th century were
thwarted in their efforts to use pop the
political system to to build uh an
economic power base
i would
i would just add this too that
you know when smalls
basically ends his political career
we find him
continuing to fight
we find him
in 1895 in the south carolina
constitutional convention which had been
called
to reverse everything that had been done
or at least to i need to rephrase that
to reverse to reverse the most essential
thing
that had been done
in the 1868 constitutional convention
which was to enfranchise african
americans
and we saw him with five other
african-americans
stand up
and do their best to try to prevent the
disfranchisement
of black south carolinians
uh that work remains unfinished because
of what's going on right now today
in south carolina under the guise of
voter id
and it's happening in other places too
so
this is robert smalls unfinished work
that
all of us have a responsibility to take
up
and to continue and to push forward
and to work with all other progressive
forces
that understand what's going on here
because
the dismantling of the right to vote in
the 1890s
in south carolina and other places in
the south was the precursor
to the the massive
oppression
of people across the board in every
aspect of life
so we need to we need to take up this
effort
and to do what smalls did and hopefully
we will be more successful than than he
was able to be although he gave every
ounce of his energy in 1895.
i think we've got time for a few more
questions sir can i respond oh i'm sorry
one moment
i think it speaks to the point that dr
delaney made earlier when he said when
does or when did the civil rights
movement start
for african-americans it started at the
very beginning and robert smalls was
part of
that ongoing struggle to secure
important rights for african-americans
and it reminds me of the saying that
says people must
forever be vigilant in terms of holding
on to and maintaining those
positive changes that came out of that
struggle so that's part of that work
that can continues to
be done
sir
question
yes my name is robert david ross
and i'm with the i'm an artist a
performing artist with the south
carolina arts commission
now my
question is and
comments i have two questions
is that uh since robert smalls was um
very concerned about education he was
really passionate about that
now the robert small started
the public school system
in america
are just in the state of south carolina
and also to add to that
since we
lack um visual images of great african
americans especially our robert smalls
we would like to suggest
that
uh we would like to have an image
a picture a color picture
of robert smalls and every
public
and private school in the state of south
carolina because it would be a good
motivating factor for our youth who have
been struggling and their self-esteem to
being associated with an african and to
see rob a small picture as they're
coming into the school it would generate
a sense of pride
to say this
african was about education i can be
like him i can motivate him but we need
those images in the schools and we would
like to hear the response from the panel
and
for them to assist us in this effort
because we need
men and women of courage here in the
state of south carolina we need help
and i would like for you to respond and
i thank you thank you
[Applause]
robert smalls started well proposed the
the resolution to create the public
school system in south carolina not in
the united states of america
public schools of course go back to the
18th century common schools uh
in boston in new england
the south didn't have public schools and
again that was one of the
the contributions that du bois pointed
out in in that article that i cited
earlier that
in the south there was no public school
system no no common schools primarily
because we had slaveholders
who who dominated the politics in in the
states
in the southern states and and basically
they didn't want to spend their tax
dollars to educate people who were not
slave holders they send their children
to the north overseas
and dirt farming ups up country white
people
weren't of any interest to them and they
definitely didn't want to
educate the enslaved african americans
so
again i teach african-american history
one of the one of my great stories is
always to tell about robert smalls his
proposing the legislation or the
resolution to create the public school
systems did not match it with in texas
an african-american from harrison county
also proposed a legislation in texas to
create the public school system so
indeed
robert smalls again and he's more
intimately by the way he's more
intimately involved in creating the
public school system down in beaufort
county okay
and i want to add one point to
dr delaney's commentary and that is that
there were no widespread
public schools in south carolina you do
have a few
instances where
planters or other individuals set up
schools
for their families and in some cases a
few cases
african-americans were allowed to attend
but again there weren't any widespread
public schools
right in fact in fact there are there
are public schools in charleston uh
before the war
but interestingly enough they were
called pauper schools
they're called pauper school because you
know the feeling was if you had if you
had money
you would send your children to private
schools you know you wouldn't you
wouldn't send them to these marginalized
uh
public schools
and even today charleston has a has a
rate of private school attendance that's
higher than the national average so
there's there's a real legacy of a
private school education that carries
over even to today in charleston
on your question about images there are
at least three civil war images of
robert smalls and from which a very good
portrait could be made from there
probably are numerous more uh beaufort
was filled with photographers and
obviously he went to these studios to
have his picture taken
sir
my name is
my name is don priolo um i don't have a
question i have a point of information
i'd like to share with the panel
and and curriculum specialists and the
like uh my son is a history teacher
in alabama and uh he he's visited
south carolina a limited amount of time
the last time we of all places didn't
get to go to fort sumter as first on the
agenda i've worked that for something
since he was here the last time and
michael in them allowed me to film
me and my peers working on the
restoration project
in at fort sumter he told me my son
asked me for uh my daddy's medals of
world war ii and i was able to tell him
that daddy worked on uh i mean was under
general mark clark fifth army
he went in italy france
north africa
and these kinds of things so
he says
they are allowed as teachers just to get
this information history out now that's
where i'm going with this
he can use real life images because he
himself when i took him to the mouth he
said i don't believe it was no slaves i
took him other places on a self-guided
tour so his students would become more
interested if he can say
my father and my grandfather this this
in charleston
and uh they can use these real life
images and teaching
history as he as they see fit
so i thought that that was an excellent
instrument that a teacher could use at
that level to get
children
to appreciate and like history i just
wanted to share that with you because
when i substituted i didn't i don't
recall you know as i walked
i had took i taught i subbed in
different classes i didn't see i don't
think i saw a lot of that but i thought
that that was an excellent way to get
them
into history and appreciate it more when
they could teachers could be allowed to
do that
thank you any
comments
i have two quick
questions and then we're going to wrap
it up and this let's make this sort of
our speed round so quick questions and
quick answers
um
first
any any quick comments about how did
america
think about perceive react to the story
of robert smalls when when sort of news
came out someone mentioned that uh you
know at the time generally slaves were
considered beasts of burden you know
without capacity of
you know
big thinking strategic thinking and the
like um and how did that
differ the the reaction differ in the
south versus in the north quick question
well quick answer the south probably
kept their mouth shut because they
didn't want robert smalls example
so we say
influencing the other slaves
so oftentimes when you see slaves escape
there might be a quick flurry in the
newspaper then they don't talk about it
anymore
the republican newspapers tended to give
smalls a great play harper's weekly gave
him great play democratic uh anti-wars
newspapers will not
so there's a great variety and that's
one thing that dupont and interestingly
enough percival drayton the south
carolinian who was with dupont
said that robert smalls needs to be
shown as an example to other people in
the north to show them that their
stereotypes are not correct
and then
last question
i think now
generally people know the the story the
gist of the story are there any tidbits
any
things that people don't typically know
that we should bring out any nuances of
the story any particulars that uh
that we should bring out in our closing
moments
well i'll i'll take a stab at this and
go back to your question about who in
the 20th century
and i'm going to kind of get at it from
sort of a backwards type of movement
here
two individuals that are associated with
the sea islands around port royal robert
smalls obviously a native another
individual who comes down and is at penn
center to help plan his strategy in the
1960s both are very articulate both are
very well known for their speeches if
nothing else at least a lot of robert
smalls of speeches are written down and
they're wonderful things he has
wonderful sense of humor and the 1895
convention and such when he uh
makes
comments back at pittsford ben tillman
and others as well
both are extremely brave
uh robert smalls never went around armed
after the civil war there were threats
against him he once commented uh when
you face down an eight-inch confederate
cannon these little pistols mean nothing
to you
and both were pacifists uh both were
pacifists and when they carried out
their political agendas they were
pacifists in doing and you asked the
body 20th century while i'll give to you
martin luther king and robert smalls
and and just to just to amplify steve's
point about about the bravery i mean we
forget about that a lot of times but
for smalls and those other
african-american men in 1895 at the
constitutional convention to oppose
disfranchisement
and and this was this really was an act
of courage and bravery
but these men had been through so much
already just just as you said
but the
but the other point that i want to make
is that in the constitutional convention
of course was ben tillman former
governor
and now senator from south carolina and
ben tillman had participated in the
hamburg massacre of african number he
was a participant he was a murderer you
see so to stand up and to stand up
toe-to-toe with ben tillman was a
supreme act of bravery and that's the
kind of medal these men have
and it was an act of bravery because
many times he was certainly near the end
of his career a lone voice and he was
still there and he was still fighting
the good fight
any uh
thank you very much
thank you so much for coming out it's
been a long day um but it's been a
wonderful day i want to thank dr powers
dr wise dr delaney ms nichols and uh
good night
[Applause]
hello hello everyone can anyone hear me
yeah awesome yeah in the back
great um so welcome tonight uh
hello my name is matthew i work here on
the event staff and store um and on
behalf of the store owners bradley
graham and lisa muscatine i'd like to
thank you and welcome our speakers
tonight
um
so we're so just a few notes of
housekeeping before i introduce
tonight's speakers
cell phones and all other devices that
go bing would should be turned off that
would be very much appreciated um as
well as the that tonight is the sole
event um so tonight there is one event
so if i could just ask everyone to fold
up their chairs at the end of the event
and
basically lean them against at the
closest bookshelf or wall that'd be also
greatly appreciated for our event staff
and taking down the event and uh last
thing is for the q a session after the
presentation if i could ask you to step
to the side to my left right here we
have a microphone we do record this nc
spin is here as well so um for posterity
if we could just get this all on
recording that'd be wonderful thank you
so without further ado i'd like to
introduce tonight's author kate
lineberry
be free or be free or die the amazing
story of robert small's escape from
slavery to union hero is kate
lineberry's second major work following
the secret rescue an untold story of
american nurses and medics behind nazi
lines nominated for the 2014 edgar award
for best fact crime and number one the
number one wall street best uh wall
street journal bestseller b free or die
chronicles the heroic journey in the
life of robert small who in 1862 seized
a confederate steamer and sailed his way
from charleston harbor to a union
blockade
freeing himself and his family however
as all of you will soon see and learn
he's mission did not end there he would
later become the first black captain of
an army ship and enjoy an illustrious
and enjoy an illustrious career as a
state and national legislator
usa today declares that reading be free
or die is like recovering a national
heirloom that was lost stolen or buried
through decades moreover countless
publications commend
her ability to elevate often overlooked
events of history into the public
consciousness with her rich narrative
kate lineberry has made a career as a
staff writer and editor at the national
geographic as well as smithsonian
magazines
she currently resides in raleigh north
carolina
and in conversation tonight is
miss lionberry is with michael moore
where moore the great great grandson of
mr smalls
mr moore is an accomplished businessman
and currently serves as president and
ceo of the international
african-american museum in charleston
south carolina
please rejoin me in welcoming kate
lineberry and michael will wear more
well we decided before that i am going
to sort of ask the first question but uh
it feels awkward this is kate's event
and i'm sort of supporting her so i just
want to um do my part to welcome you all
here it's it's great i've had it we had
a chance to do this once before and this
looks like a great crowd and i hear it's
a friendly one
lots of uh
lots of uh folks that know her so it's
uh it's great we're gonna just do a
little bit of a q a back and forth and
in so doing i think reveal a bit more
about
the man robert smalls his life
and
and some other stuff so i think i'm
going to
start
so how did you how did robert smalls
come across your radar you've written
before
you could have written about anything
why robert smalls
yeah well thank you so much michael and
thank you so much for being here it
means the world to me to have the
support of robert smalls family and
writing this book
that was very important to me and going
into this and um and it's it's been
wonderful so thank you
um and then sorry to my friends from
national geographic many of whom are
over here who um i have my back turned
to a little bit
nothing personal i promise
but i was looking for my second
an idea for my second book after the
secret rescue came out and
it's often a difficult task because you
are trying to find a subject that you're
bringing something new to the table with
and that can be hard given how many
books there are out there
but my youngest brother actually sent me
an article about robert smalls while i
was in this process
and i was fascinated by him and
particularly fascinated by the idea that
i never heard of him because i had done
through my work at national geographic
and smithsonian and
writing for the new york times civil war
blog had read a lot of stories about the
civil war and i was amazed to find that
he was not
a better known figure
so in looking at that article i just
decided you know i wanted to know more i
wanted to know
what compelled him to take such a great
risk in stealing this seizing the ship
and taking his family with them and
risking everything after having a life
of being told that he was not equal
and so i was hooked from there i felt
like there was a room in the marketplace
for a book about robert smalls that had
been a while
and a non-academic book that was for a
mass audience
and so that's that's how i got started
with it that's great
um and of course the most obvious
question to ask you is what impacted
having a great great grandfather who is
an american hero have on you growing up
it's almost hard to know where to start
on that question
from sort of a metaphysical level
it has been profound in the sense that
you know as a young person
you grow up and i think we're all
insecure to certain degrees about a
variety of different things i had the
the benefit of growing up in the 70s in
boston which while boston massachusetts
has
you know sort of the branding as being
kind of a progressive liberal kind of a
place i can assure you that around
issues of race in the 70s it
it wasn't and i'll acknowledge my my
brother jeff back there he and i
deployed to a prep school in new england
back during those days so
thank you for coming
but uh
so
so a couple levels you know as a child
at first
i really it just it kind of it just was
i mean i i grew up with robert smalls
grandchildren my grandmother was his
granddaughter
she was born in 1897
and so
you know lived with robert
for
you know up until her teen years and
further robert's daughter
lived with my
mother and my grandparents for the last
22 years of
her life
and she had the benefit of living a long
long life she was on the planter when
robert commandeered it on may 13 1862
but she died in 1959
so
my mother grew up with you know
firsthand hearing first-hand stories
about
you know robert and you know she she
didn't she was a maybe four three four
years old or something and she didn't
remember much about that night
but she remembered being scared and
remembered you know just kind of the
i don't know if trauma is the right word
but just the experience being very sort
of scary and then obviously was able to
be much more detailed about sort of
growing up and she ended up was was his
uh secretary in washington everything so
to make a long story short um you know
it really it sustained me it it uh
it filled me with
uh or it supported my sense of
self-esteem my sense of self you know
growing up and and you know
being attacked around my sense of
identity my ethnicity my race
having somebody like robert smalls who
had accomplished something who
had
done
big things against enormous odds really
helped to
counterbalance a lot of that and and so
that was wonderful and then even to this
day i mean
uh you know i'm president of a museum in
charleston i would not be president of a
museum in charleston had i not had this
connection to robert smalls
and and so
it it it's the gift that keeps on giving
and i think for me my challenge
is how do i
continue that gift to my children i've
got four sons
and
it's
named robert yes that's right that's
right one of whom his name is robert and
so i just think it's
it's
i just feel an obligation
um and i'm i'm expressing that
obligation to some degree in my work i'm
doing at the museum but most important
around passing that along to my children
and hopefully someday my grandchildren
so it's it's it's been wonderful
so how you know when you were thinking
about robert smalls and thinking about
hey that's a cool story to some degree
there had to be something of a business
decision about relevance and about how
the story translated to today's readers
walk us through that process and why you
thought the robert small story which is
not a news story it's perhaps an
undertold story but not a news story why
that
you know could be relevant today right i
mean certainly people in beaufort know
robert small's name that is the town in
south carolina where he was born and
raised
until he was 12. but yeah there's
definitely a marketing decision a
business decision when you're picking a
topic
you know you want to make sure that you
are bringing something new to the table
like i mentioned
but there was also i think in order to
really
appeal to modern day readers who have so
many choices you want to do something
that's relevant to their lives today and
you can't pick up a newspaper or turn on
the tv without seeing some issue
regarding race in our country
it permeates every aspect of our society
and
you know robert small's story is
extraordinary on its own but if you
combine it with um
sort of the civil the the plight of
african americans during the civil war
it illustrates his story illustrates so
much and that's what really appealed to
me as well so it was telling small story
during the civil war
which is the focus of the book and then
also telling the story because in order
to understand his story you have to
understand
so many issues that african americans
were facing and so many issues that our
country was dealing with at the time
i learned so much in the research
process of this book because i had no
idea
how much of a
decision it was whether or not to free
the slaves for so long the war had gone
on for so long so when robert smalls
actually sailed to freedom with his
family he was considered contraband
technically speaking
most slaves did not see themselves that
way they considered themselves free but
technically the government of the united
states had not decided what they were
going to do
so i think in order for our country to
get past or heal from some of the racial
issues that we're dealing with we have
to fully understand the full story and
robert small's story i mean he was in
the center of everything he was
born in beaufort which was of course
near port royal sound and that was taken
over by the union in november 1861
and it became because when the union
took it over the whites in the area fled
leaving behind ten thousand enslaved men
women and children who had no food and
who did not know how to you know care
for themselves they'd never been allowed
to so the government had to figure out
how to help them and it was the
beginning of the first efforts that
reconstruction happened there um and
then of course when he was 12 he moved
to charleston south carolina and
charleston was
the place where the south carolina state
of south carolina signed the ordinance
of secession
it was the spiritual capital of the
confederacy so he was really in the
middle of it all and that was definitely
an
important aspect of the story
there's a picture of you that i've seen
several times um i think it was in the
70s maybe at tabernacle church um can
you explain um your what happened what
the relevance to robert smalls is of the
tabernacle church
well um
i've been blessed to have an opportunity
to talk about robert smalls many many
many times over the course of my life
um hundreds of times but the first time
that i spoke publicly about robert
smalls was i think april 1976
i think i was 13 or 14 years old i had
just come back from a trip to dc you
know the eighth grade trip that
everybody does to dc
and um it was
loosely it was sort of robert smalls day
in south carolina that day there was a
big parade i got a chance to ride in a
float with the lieutenant governor and
um and then afterward
um
at tabernacle baptist church where he's
buried i got an opportunity to unveil
the bust that is of him there
and
it's interesting
i remember
being
quite terrified
up to the moment thinking about speaking
in front of people
and uh
something
literally um sort of washed over me as
i'm sitting on this stage
and
sort of took that anxiety away and i've
never really felt anxious about speaking
in public before that doesn't say i do
it well but at least i've you know so um
you know whether that was uh robert sort
of uh
you know moving his hand over me or
whatever but um but yeah that was that
was a great opportunity and um
and our family
has a traveling exhibit robert smalls a
traveling exhibit that travels around
the country um has
artifacts and papers and some models and
the like about his life and typically
whenever that opens someplace i go and
do a little talk so
it's it's it's always wonderful having
an opportunity to talk about somebody
you're proud about and if that person
happens to be connected to you all the
better so and the exhibit's actually in
beaufort right now it is it is yeah it's
it's in beaufort
um
tell me about the research process you
you found out about him you decided that
this with someone who you'd be
interested in and perhaps exploring
further what is the research process
like for something like this
well i'm talking to an audience full of
a lot of researchers
[Laughter]
um
but um so i was trained by the very best
i think at national geographic many
years ago
um but uh the way i start is i cast as
wide of a net as i possibly can in the
first few weeks of and months of
starting a story so i read as much as i
can on a topic i'm kind of picking the
low hanging fruit if you will
and see what i can learn from there and
then typically from there you find other
angles of
places where you want to research of
course i knew that
robert smalls pension
files were in the national archives
and that was something that
once he sailed the ship to freedom
the union ended up hiring him as a
civilian boat pilot
he could have been enlisted as i believe
that the other men who were on board
that ship were but
dupont samuel dupont who is the admiral
that took the ship from smalls
needed him as a pilot and the only level
that robert smalls could be enlisted as
would be boy which is the very lowest um
not a very well respected position and
he certainly never would have been
allowed to be a boat pilot and he needed
him as a boat pilot he was very
impressed with his navigational skills
and everything else he had done
so um for many years smalls had to fight
for a pension he served in numerous
battles throughout the uh war
um in all you know in every way he was a
enlisted man but technically he was not
so i knew that those pension
files would be very relevant to his
story and it was you know it was very
amazing to see um some of the writing
the handwriting and these notes that
there that are still at the archives um
and then the hagley museum in wilmington
delaware
they have because of dupont's connection
to the story they have a lot of the
papers that were delivered when smalls
turned over the boat they have the order
book that was on the planner they have
confederate
passes and for me there's nothing like
seeing something like that in person
it just makes the story so real
some of the museums some of the archives
in south carolina also had items and
um and then one of the i think i
mentioned this the last time we spoke
but one of the most
sort of upsetting uh documents that i
came across was a bill of sale for
small's future wife hannah
when she was still they had not met yet
and it was in the 1840s and he
she was sold along with her children for
800
to samuel kingman her new owner and
seeing that on a piece of paper was just
brought this history to life in a way
that reading about it just can't as a
white person doing the story i think it
it um
it hit home in a way that i hadn't
realized it would
as i'm sure it would for anyone who was
who was looking at these documents so
going to these archives finding as much
material um i never in my wildest dreams
thought that i would find family members
that i could
count on for this book
with my world war ii story i thought it
was a little bit easier but um certainly
did not think there would be people
actively
preserving small story and lo and behold
dr helen bulwar moore who is michael's
mother has done this traveling exhibit
michael's the speaker for the family now
is the president of the museum in
charleston
um and takes this uh subject very
seriously and is clearly passionate
about it so that made it a lot easier
too i mean when you see the impact um i
mean i can see through your family the
impact that uh education has had in your
lives seems like it's something that
your mom has her phd you know you have
your mba
smalls was illiterate until he was in
his 20s and
education became very important to him
he saw that as a way to freedom and he
passed that along to his children
and i think that was really
instilled in the family it seems like
something you all value very much
so you know i i try to turn over every
leaf i can when doing research and um
you never know where that's going to be
i was really
determined to find out
henry mckee's reaction henry mckee was
small's owner
i wanted to find out his reaction to
smalls
seizing the planter and
there was not a lot of information out
there but in a
family diary that was published
there was a small mention that he was
working in a confederate hospital in
colombia during the war and he had just
lost two children from um from illness
and
quickly just mentioned that he knew
about it so you know it wasn't the big
aha moment that i'd hoped to get with
lots of description of his reaction but
it was it was important to me to know
what kind of reaction he had so you
never know where that's going to come up
and the fact that so many newspaper
articles are being digitized and so much
material is being digitized now that
really helps a lot um
saves hours and hours of time
can i ask a follow-up yeah
so um
part of the reason why the robert small
story is not better known is because for
for certain parts of the country there
was a strategic effort to sort of mute
the story you know
somebody
during in 2012 we had a
sesquicentennial commemoration in
charleston
commemorating uh smalls taking the boat
to freedom and someone came up to me
afterward uh very emotional very upset
and said you know
you know i'm angry with you because
robert smalls my
you know history my ancestors traced to
the confederacy and robert smalls
embarrassed the confederacy
and i i'm not quite sure what response
he expected of me
and i wanted to be sure not to
disrespect him personally
but i you know
but um but i just wonder
you know if you were doing a book about
abe lincoln there'd be not all there'd
be in addition to sort of original
research there'd be all kinds of other
authors who had uncovered things and
with robert smalls there probably wasn't
a whole lot of that and then there was
this whole influence
of uh of sort of
you know
muting again sort of that story i just
wonder how that played if at all in your
research oh no it's um it's it's one of
the challenges that i think um people
are doing non-fiction you know we can
only write what we can validate and we
can really i mean you can throw in only
so many probabilities and possibly's and
um so which i certainly did
but um
but yeah it's definitely um an issue and
the fact that he was illiterate for
until he was in his 20s there were not a
lot of writings
to go back on his daughter your
great-grandmother did a lot of his
writing for him later in life
so it was definitely
something i had to think long and hard
about do i have enough material here to
make this book come to life and i hope i
did
but it's definitely a consideration and
you know that's why it's so important to
find as many sources as you possibly can
um but in in you're asking that question
it reminded me of um
in i met one of the descendants who
actually you introduced me to of charles
realier who was the captain the white
captain on board the planter the night
that smalls seized the ship
um relia had decided that he and his
fellow white officers would go into town
and spend time with their families which
was against confederate orders
thus leaving the area open for smalls to
do what he did it was still miraculous
that he was able to do it but this
allowed it to happen in some ways so
you've you know we've met the charles
rallier's descendant and he told me when
we interviewed when i talked to him that
he was really the first generation
to not be embarrassed by the story and
he's very open to playing to his role um
and came to our reading in charleston
and has embraced it but i think that
speaks volumes to um the legacy of um
of the south and of of the the division
in the country in some ways
um so my question back to you would be
about the descendants and what it was
like for you to meet and who did you
meet and what it was like for you to
meet them
yeah it's it's been really surreal to
meet these descendants of other people
i've had a chance i met
this gentleman relie i met a descendant
of the family that owned the planter
i met
a great great grandson of samuel f
dupont up in philadelphia at a museum
event
and um
i sort of think of it abstractly i
to some degree i you know 150 years ago
all those people's lives were
intersecting and then they
broke apart
and then you know 150 years later the
arc of those lives kind of came back
together
and uh
and it's it's it's interesting it's it's
odd how that happens um
but uh you know i
i would love to
get as many of those descendants
together around a table and just talk
about what did you hear what did you
hear what what you know what did you
sort of grow up hearing you know that
dupont
descendant really didn't know much about
it at all and you know
um
i think being with dupont you probably
have lots of other things to think about
but um
but yeah it uh it's been it's been
interesting it's been fascinating and um
you know i think uh
picked up little things here and there
and so it's been fun yeah great
um
again robert smalls is sort of an
undertold story um
were there things as you did your
research as you were beginning writing
that really sort of surprised you or let
me pose that another way what surprised
you most
about the story
i think what surprised me the most was
how i thought i knew a lot about what
had happened during that time beyond
robert smalls
about african-american relationships um
to their owners etc etc and i found that
a lot of it was not exactly as i thought
or it was a lot um
i mean the brutality was certainly there
i was certainly aware of that but i
think that the um
how much the lives of the people were
intertwined and um you know and
i found that robert was in such a unique
position because he his mother lydia was
born as you know on the mckee plantation
and at the age of just nine years old
she was taken to the house in town the
beaufort house to raise the mckee
children
ripped from her her mother
and but she spoke gullah which was the
language
spoken by a lot of the west african
slaves who had had their own languages
but were pushed together on these
plantations and had to come up with a
way to communicate with each other
so he had the benefit of
speaking gala and knowing the gulli
culture as well as understanding how to
operate in mckee's world and he was also
privy to a lot of information because he
was
working as a house slave
which i didn't realize the extent of the
difference between that
certainly no one would ever wish anyone
to be a an enslaved person working at
home but compared to life on a
plantation
it was a far better life there was
regular food regular clothes and you
were
aware of a lot that was going on so i
think that was one of the most shocking
things um
i was also really shocked to find out in
the aftermath of the civil war the
extent to which the south tried to
reinstate slavery i kind of knew it but
i didn't know to the extent when black
codes were ins
uh implemented
and
it was it was quite shocking and i think
that's kind of the history i was talking
about
that we all need to understand more um
to fully grasp the history
so
um
i would ask you is there anything in
reading the book that surprised you
i think i read the first book about
robert smalls there was a children's
book um
back you know in the 60s and
and
i love books this kind of an environment
is home for me so i love
being around books i i think
for me it's it's it was an incremental
kind of a kind of an experience every
time you
hear a new detail or you
read about something that you didn't
know it sort of it almost feels like
you're opening a door to some
information that maybe that information
was there but for some reason you just
hadn't accessed it or something
for me it was just
broadly
there were lots of details i think your
research was fabulous
but i think holistically it was just
sort of this uncovering of new
information and
and it also um to a certain degree
because i feel inextricably linked to
him
it's like learning a bit more about your
own identity and to some degree that's
kind of odd it's odd um you know kate
and i are just getting to know each
other and he or she is telling me you
know kind of something about who i am
kind of a thing and that's i've had to
get used to that you know over the over
the years but um but no it's it's uh
it's been fascinating
how did you
in thinking about writing the book and
and sort of fashioning the story you
made a strategic decision to stop in a
certain place can you talk about that
point and why you decided there as
opposed to continuing to talk about
other things um because of course
you're referring to the fact that i mean
after the war robert smalls went on to
have an incredible career he served as a
congressman for five terms
um did some amazing things um faced a
lot of trials and tribulations certainly
had death threats um during
reconstruction and the aftermath of the
war but for me um i felt that the civil
war was
what made him the person he was well his
childhood as well as
the civil war and it launched him into
this political career and i wasn't
personally i wasn't as interested in
getting into the
details about certain legislation and i
really wanted to tell the story of him
as a person
and
you know as much as you can without
having access to diaries and things like
that but
but to me you know first of all the
seizing of the planner is sexy and
exciting and um and everybody wants to
know more about it but also
understanding you know um kind of
ripping off the the covers of what it
was like for a 12 year old boy to be
sent to charleston on his own
without anyone you know being his
guardian really he was expected he was
hired out for work
and was expected to turn over most of
that paycheck he was allowed to save a
dollar
um
each month but um
you know that that was important to me
and that's what i felt like made him the
man that he became so i was able to talk
about the his life after the civil war
in the epilogue but i really wanted to
focus on what made him the person that
he became
yeah
let's see i think we have i'll ask you
one more question and then we'll move to
some questions from the audience so be
thinking
um
i used the term enslaved person
throughout the book
in addition to slave whenever it felt
right to me
that was the decision that my editor and
i made particularly after speaking to
your mother
who really enlightened me about the
issue i wondered if you could talk a
little bit about
because i know through facebook and
other means i know that that's a prefer
preferred term for you as well
i
i think um you know there's been a long
journey from
those days when robert smalls are around
um to
for for african americans to kind of
seize the narrative of
you know sort of our lives our existence
our identity
um
and so broadly i think it fits into that
stream of
sort of
evolution
identity evolution
more personally
it's been sort of passed down
through the generations that lydia
robert's mother said to him when he was
young
that robert
you may be enslaved but you are not a
slave
and i think the distinction that she was
trying to offer was that this may be the
condition that you're in but this
doesn't define who you are
you know there's a difference between an
adjective and a noun
um and so
the combination of kind of this
and and
i don't know the last decade or so i
think people have been starting to make
that distinction
and the fact that i've got like some
personal
um connection to that thinking i think
you know resonates with me you know
people of african descent have been
around since the you know since the
first human beings um the history
uh in this country is like this much you
know in in the span of of time and and
so i don't think that
defines
those people who suffered through that i
think that was
yeah what the the role that they were
forced to play well and i found even in
in my writing when i would talk about
enslaved men women and children it
reminded me of their humanity in so many
ways you would read i read countless
articles about the suffering that was
happening with the people that were left
behind by the whites when they fled uh
port royal and beaufort but when you
start you know you start kind of
grouping people together and and you
know the slaves did this or they need
this and then when you start talking
about individual people
men women children it becomes much more
powerful to people as well
yeah i think
just to talk really for just a minute
about this museum that we're building
one of the galleries that we are
building is called atlantic connections
and it seeks to
uncover
it seeks to to talk about this point you
know the fact is is that you know the
people who came here the africans who
came to america it wasn't this
monolithic group of people it was people
were from hundreds of different
ethnicities and languages and religions
and
who who came from accomplished
civilizations and so
um
you know i think that that
understanding that i think adds to this
sense of humanity that you just talked
about i think is important great
um well with that uh does anyone have
any questions they'd like to ask i think
they want you to come to the microphone
hello hi um
thank you very much for your words i'm
finding the book to be truly meaningful
um
um for me one of the most moving aspects
of the book
was learning about how robert smalls
ultimately purchased
um the house in boom um
um
in boumant um
in beaufort yeah um thank you thank you
um
in buford that um um in which he and his
mother had been enslaved um my question
is um
um
what happened to the house is the house
still standing today if it is is it a
museum is it privately owned
do you want to answer dylan yeah
it's uh the house remained in our family
for about a hundred years and um in the
1950s or so late 1950s just about
everybody had left beaufort beaufort had
fallen on kind of hard economic times
and so
lots of my family ended up in charlotte
throughout north and south carolina and
so the decision was made
you know sort of a business decision
that to sell the house so now it's in
private hands it's on the national
register of historic sites or
but uh but but it's a private residence
great question thank you
i'm not sure there's a good question so
if it's not i i apologize in advance but
it's all it's on my mind so i'm going to
ask it anyway uh
uh i haven't read the book yet but i i
can't wait to i just finished reading uh
um
douglas edgerton's book about
the massachusetts 54th and 55th
regiments and i saw a reference to
robert smalls in the book and i said man
i got to read a book read about that guy
and then your book came out so i'm
really happy to see it and i'm uh i'm
impressed with you you appear to be
uh a relatively fearless kind of person
who would take on a new subject and and
not worry about it but i i i i is back
there
i just i'm somewhat curious about the
the quote quote-unquote racial aspect of
this uh in the sense of you being uh i
don't like white and black i i realize
that there's social constructs and all
that but uh so you know
uh
you being you uh writing about uh an
african-american hero and i just
wondered
what your what your thoughts were
before you took that on and
how things transpired as you as you got
into it if it was important or not it
was incredibly important i mean i think
i would be very naive as a writer um to
go into any topic without kind of
thinking about every angle you possibly
can
certainly
with a topic that deals with race
whatever topic that is
you've got to be ready um to make sure
that all your facts are correct that one
of the things that was most important to
me was being as sensitive as i possibly
could to the issue so that involved
having
a professor who is a specialist in
african-american history and who's
african-american himself read the book
the manuscript once it was done i
consulted with him throughout the
process
certainly having the family of robert
smalls whether he was white black or
asian was very important to me because i
my goal as a writer is to
is not to
put anyone down that's not my goal is to
get the accurate story and in this case
i wanted to elevate someone that i
believed was a hero
but it was very important to me to
listen to any issues that came up like
when
michael's mother mentioned the we were
going to use the term slave on the title
his journey from slavery to union hero
from slave to union hero
and she was opposed to that and um and i
completely understand why now and we
made that argument with the editor who
was very gracious about it and
understood and the last thing i wanted
to do was to um insult people that i was
really trying to help by telling the
story the small smalls family
so
you know it was kind of a daunting thing
i don't know if i fully realized how
daunting it was when i started i was
really just overwhelmed by his story and
i think he is an american hero that we
should all be looking to
um beyond being african-american or i
mean obviously that was an important
aspect of his story but
but that's really what made me decide to
do it is that you know he's an american
hero and i wanted people to know him and
you know hopefully i'd be as sensitive
as possible and i i
relied a lot on a lot of cold readers i
had many many people read it and alerted
me to anything that they felt was
insensitive towards the confederates as
well i think that's you know
something you have to you know it is our
past i personally got interested in the
civil war when i was younger when i
learned that
i had relatives who fought on both sides
of the war at the battle of gettysburg
both were injured the confederate went
to a couple pow camps and
you know i thought that was something
that made me a good candidate to write
the story because i think that i
i live in raleigh north carolina now i
think i have i've lived in washington dc
for almost 20 years before living again
in raleigh and so
in a long very long-winded answer to
your question
it was something that was very much on
my mind and i hope that i um
covered everything i could but i was
willing to take the chance to get his
story out
thank you
i know your focus is on the civil war um
but i
but i have read
about how robert smalls was one of the
last african-american leaders to remain
in power
as the segregationist basically pushed
out african-american leaders and he had
control over his constitu his
constituents in both in beaufort um can
you comment on why
um why that why that happened why he was
that
that question control maybe you're
welcome
i think it was really um
yeah robert smalls actually served
longer than any other african-american
congressman during reconstruction and i
think that was largely across five terms
was largely because buford was so
overwhelmingly african-american at the
time so there were all sorts of efforts
by uh you know the the red shirts and
others to sort of
you know
grab power again but
for the longest there was a you know
real block of african-american sort of
voting power in beaufort that allowed to
sustain him is that
yeah and i think um
you know unfortunately he he
faced a lot of discrimination throughout
his career and ultimately at one point
was accused of bribery
um was sentenced to three years hard
labor
um but only served three days before he
was essentially pardoned but he really
wanted to go to the supreme court and
argue his case because he firmly
believed that he was not guilty and it
was an effort to take him down and his
career did suffer a little bit from that
so the last bit of his career he was the
customs collector in beaufort but i
think
i think his long reign in beaufort
speaks to the kind of person he was i
think he was
respected not only by the
african-american community community but
also by the whites in the area
one of the stories that you'll hear if
you go to beaufort and go to his home or
go on a tour or pass the home is that
smalls reached out to the mckee family
who had owned him and his mother and
invited them to come back to the house
and paid for their air their
rail trip to beaufort and invited them
to stay with him which was extraordinary
act of forgiveness in in my book
and the mckee family
refused to eat with him at the same
table
but he continued to have them stay at
his home and he served them separately
so i think a lot of his
success was determined by the kind of
person he was
despite the efforts to knock him down
hi um
i haven't read your book but i just have
a couple of questions
um
smalls was uh regarding his pension
i know that um there was some struggle
regarding the um
uh him um being able to obtain this
pension
the um
i know he served under samuel dupont
and i think it was robert uh
robert david hunter who was the uh army
commander
i'm just curious uh so he was as i
understand he was promoted to the rank
of a captain
or pilot
which
should have um allowed him to to receive
his uh pension
when he requested uh when he
did the investigation regarding his
pension
i'm i don't understand why he didn't
call on samuel dupont or david honor to
assist him
in verifying the facts so that he would
be able to get his pension now i
understand he later received his pension
but i'm a little confused as to why
there was a struggle initially for him
to receive the pension do you want me to
answer that
yeah well he was he was promoted to a
captain but it was not in a military
capacity he was captain of a ship and
that happened um shortly after he was uh
piloting boats during the charleston
campaign um they got close to some fire
and the white captain of the ship at the
time panicked and hid in the bunker
and the coal bunker and smalls jumped in
and because he was so heroic and saved
many lives um they immediately said
let's make this guy a captain but he was
not a military captain he was captain of
that boat um hunter died dupont died
shortly um
during the war soon after he was
he lost his position because of what had
happened in charleston
and and i don't remember exactly when
hunter died but i know that for many
years smalls actually fought to get a
pension for hunter's wife
after he died so this is the kind of man
he was he was looking out for people who
had helped him
but so i think it all comes down to the
idea that he was a civilian
boat pilot he was never an enlisted man
he pretty much did it but he if he had
been enlisted he wouldn't have been
allowed to be a pilot so
what choice did he have
um but the other side of that coin is
that as an african-american he faced
certain obstacles in the process that he
wouldn't otherwise for example
there was a law on the books that when
property was delivered to the union that
a certain
formula was delivered to in terms of a
reward and smalls never got that for
what he delivered as congress couldn't
see fit to give
a black man that much money so i think i
think it was it was complicated let's
just say one final question did he have
a relationship with um
frederick douglass
yeah he absolutely did and he and
frederick douglass um
met with secretary of war stanton and in
fact with president lincoln around
trying to lobby to get
formerly enslaved men to be included in
the in the union
and by the way there are also a number
of letters back and forth between the
two men some of which are in the uh
exhibit that we have
hi
i have a sort of writing process
question i was in tim wendell's class
when you came and talked to us about the
secret rescue and i was just curious
about how you feel like either your
voice changed or just your
maybe approach to organizing this book
changed from your first
major piece uh to this one that's a
great question i got my master's degree
in writing from johns hopkins and tim
wendell was my thesis advisor and so i
spoke to your class
and i think it's an excellent question i
think the first time you try to write a
book you have no idea what you're doing
and you know your editor wants you to
have it done by a certain deadline and
they're certainly not holding your hand
so i think my experience with as being a
researcher at national geographic
really compelled me to make sure that i
got every single detail right for both
books but i think that what i learned in
the process of writing the secret rescue
is you have to humanize the characters
more as well i mean i was so afraid of
attributing something that didn't really
happen
um that i was probably a little bit
gun-shy about that so i think
and i think with experience you know you
you gain so much
you understand the process you
understand what kind of feedback you'll
be getting from your editor and um so
it's definitely a learning process and
uh i think getting your legs on the
first book is to be expected unless
there are far better writers out there
than i am so
hi hi
first of all let me thank you so much
for doing this because i do have uh and
many of us do uh dr andrew billingsley
book on smalls and uh in in reading that
and and coming to hear him many of us
felt there was need for more of a
personal story about small himself and
you have done that
where were you in the process and i'll
ask both of you
when the massacre mother emanuel
occurred and what do you think
the impact will be from that on your
work as well as your work
at the
museum ahead
talk sorry about the book um well i was
i had written the proposal it had gone
around with my agent had taken it to
publishers and we had a publisher
interested
and had acquired the book and so
i think when this
horrific event happened
it just reiter reiterated the idea that
this was such a relevant story to today
reverend clementa pinckney who is one of
the unfortunate victims of this terrible
shooting um was actually in a position
that smalls had served in and admired
robert smalls
i think it was skip gates um a professor
at harvard who had interviewed him and
he had specifically mentioned robert
smalls so it was very poignant to me i
was already invested in the story i was
you know working on it and wanting it to
be the best i could but it was a
shocking reminder just how much we still
how far we have to go in this country
and i did visit it on one of my further
trips to charleston and it was just um
there were a lot of flowers still out it
had been months and months but it was
a pretty moving
moment and
just just a tragedy
i think in trying to build a museum that
seeks to
tell
these untold stories like robert smalls
and so many others
there are a lot of challenges and and um
you know former mayor riley who
conceived of this museum 40 years that's
right for 40 years yeah he he actually
first talked about the museum in his
state of the city address in the year
2000. so
it's been out there it's been
percolating along for a long time i
think at first the mayor had to build
sort of the political case to explain
why
we needed this museum and believe it or
not
you know i'll i'll say this humbly and
with respect um you know there were a
lot of people then as there are some now
in charleston who don't really
understand why we need this museum
you know charleston is this really
beautiful city and i think mayor riley
has done an amazing job in sort of
building it but there's an element sort
of a romantic antebellum old south kind
of a
element that drives a lot of the major
industry which is tourism
that really
is uneasy about
african american history and certainly
the role that that played in building
charleston and in building this nation
and so i think to your question
when the massacre at mother emanuel
occurred i think it immediately caused
people to it was shocking of course to
everyone
and it caused people to rethink
um these relationships and things that
everyone thought was
you know these issues that
everyone thought you know were kind of
being managed or or we're okay
and and for me now
a couple years later it is um
it's really
it's a very powerful influence on things
in our office if if i was standing in
the front door right now mother emanuel
church would be closer than that front
door
it's right across the street
um so you mentioned about the flowers i
mean every more you know every day
i see people go and sort of pay respects
and leave flowers and other sorts of
things
it remains
you know and of course just to take a
step back you know with the trials and
and so that the legal process continues
to sort of progress on that i mean it's
just kind of hanging there
um and charleston continues to evolve
and to grow and to try to figure out how
to deal with these kinds of things and i
think the museum hopes to try to be a
part of contributing to those
conversations in productive and positive
ways so i mean there there's a great
tour in this and with the work at the
museum and i was going to ask how can we
as average citizens and supporters help
uh you know in what you're doing and you
have a lot of truth here and the one
thing that i'd like to see come out of
that museum i'm a frequent visitor to
charleston and i certainly have been
into mother emanuel and did my first
communion there the year after in terms
of the first sunday uh
but uh is to tell the truth to tell the
truth because it has been so hidden and
and and kept uh secret and hidden
despite the romanticism because
charleston is a beautiful beautiful
senate and now i bring forth my friend
cindy who is a charlestonian right now
no i am not i wish i had that pedigree
um i'm from south carolina but i don't
have the charleston pedigree and it is a
great
distinction
the people from charleston are greatly
uh
hell and great esteem black and white
from the rest of the state
but my question has to do you know i
know you did a lot of research and
a bit of a research of myself so i
really have a lot of respect for that
but
this is an untold story to the nation
but within the state of south carolina
certainly within the african-american
community we grew up with this story
it so there's an oral history
that's very strong throughout the state
and i was
assumed much stronger in beaufort and
and charleston so my question is do you
have any
uh oral history that you tapped into
to get the perspective of the people
there because robert smalls every other
person i know i was telling veronica
claims to be
and i just talked to you about that
descended from robin's mouth because it
because of the power right of his
persona right
um so my question is really did you get
any oral history
um
to contribute to your understanding of
what happened yeah absolutely great
question did i get any oral history um
to contribute to the telling of the
story and absolutely um you know i think
not only going to places where your
story takes place is so important to get
the feel of a place but you have to talk
to people who who have opinions and you
know oftentimes things are wrong that
sometimes get passed down but oftentimes
they're right and you know i was
fortunate in that dr moore michael's
mother um you know grew up with
as her grandmother elizabeth who was
four years old on the planter so you
know when when uh helen tells me
something i i believe helen
and
and most of her material i was that i
was able to verify was absolutely true
so i think you know as a researcher
you you want to get that oral history
and then you have to evaluate it based
on sources because it was very important
to me to not um just
reiterate stories that have been passed
down that don't have any in any basis in
truth
but oftentimes oral history is a great
uh great beginning and i think it's an
important part to get a full story
just just as a corollary to that the
question about
the race
being an issue
for you as an author i think it's
extremely important to recognize this
man
as an american hero not as an
african-american hero had he been white
and delivered that ship
yeah it would have been a great act yeah
he'd have been president
no i don't mean it that way but i mean
but the the fact that it was hidden and
not spoken about more generally yeah and
with the help of the texas uh board of
education made sure that it's not in any
of the
of the um of the uh history books
um but it it is but it was very much a
part of the the lore and then part of
the pride yeah of the of the people of
south carolina well i think i mean your
point is excellent it's one that i
thought about over and over again about
this this is an american story and of
course um you know who who's robert
smalls father was is unknown and he was
likely white i mean this is a story that
is
a black and white story i mean it's it's
you know we don't have to put labels on
it he's an american hero that i think
every child should know about in schools
and um
you know one one quick thing i wanted to
bring up about um the museum is that um
i don't know if you know but it's going
to be on the site of gadsden's wharf do
you want to talk about why that's that's
important thank you for your question
yeah and thank you for the prompt um
we have the
wonderful
blessing to be able to create a museum
on the site that where almost half of
all the enslaved africans who came to
america took their first steps
so it's really sacred ground
you know
there's an amazing
african-american history museum in this
city
and i hope you all had a chance to
to be there
its leader lonnie bunch says
uh he told us one time that you know
there are very very few sacred sites of
african american history in the entire
continent
hemisphere you said but that gadsden's
wharf where you you're building a museum
is one of them so it's it's uh we have
an enormous opportunity i i um
i like to position it as an opportunity
but most of the times i think of it as a
responsibility and you know i think of
uh
you know it's it's a it's an obligation
um and i think
you know sort of the north star for me
in this project i have two one is the
ancestors
you know we have to create this
in a way that makes them proud
and then the other is my children
and we've got to build this in a way
that uh delivers that legacy and those
stories to them and helps them to you
know have a firm understanding of who
they are so it's uh it's really
important work
and i'm blessed to be able to do it
we have time for one more quick question
thank you so much for uh both of you
being here i'm trying to speak into this
um i haven't had the pleasure of reading
the book as if yet but you know what
stood out tonight is your constant
mentioning
of mr smalls being taken to charleston
at age 12
and as someone who has ken in charleston
and is there quite often
you know if you go to the avery
institute you see the badges that
african descendant people had to wear
just to get a few steps around town
you understand that the town has
survived plagues and epidemics that uh
matters of science medicine construction
art
all have hearty contribution from
african descendant people that are very
physically present so it's very mocking
that you know charles and i sense that
spirit you described earlier about
charleston kind of avoiding race
and i'm just wondering if
you've said a lot tonight but can you
say more about
especially a man being brought to that
city
strictly ordered the holy city was
strictly ordered
um
how does he fit into that
kind of
history and extension of it thank you
can i go ahead
i think charleston was a
was a really unique
place
in the institution of slavery
there were
traditional
um
sort of plantation enslaved people
people
you know rice was
uh the
real economic driver in colonial america
most people don't know charleston was
the richest city in america for over a
hundred years we're not that old as a
country charleston was the richest city
because of rice and because of the
profitability of slavery 17 i think 17
out of
the richest 18 people
in the country were in charleston the
richest man in the world was in
charleston back in colonial america
so it was charleston was a lot
happening so traditionally sort of
plantation enslaved people there were
on the other end of the spectrum free
people free people of color as they call
them and then there were people like
robert and his wife hannah who were
more sort of urban enslaved folks robert
and hannah lived in an apartment above a
barn on east bay street
and so my sense is from what i've read
from what i understand there was this
really creative mix of
people and
they interacted with each other they
learned from each other they grew
and it it i i don't think robert
i think that was one of the reasons why
robert was able to do what he did was
because not only did he grow up
um
the circumstances that he grew up in
allowed him to dream big dreams and then
to try to
wonder well
why aren't i you know why aren't i free
but then he was around people that was a
stimulating you know kind of a social
situation as well so i don't know that
this directly answers your question but
i think from my perspective that's
that's part of it but yeah
and i would say just to add quickly that
robert smalls what i found in doing the
book is that he embraced every
opportunity that came his way so
charleston had a lot of restrictions in
place the slave badges et cetera
but he
found ways around them and that's what's
particularly extraordinary about his
story he was determined to create a life
for himself
that was not um determined by someone
else and that's remarkable to me
thank you the one thing if we have just
another 30 seconds but but i think it's
it's relevant to this
um it always
it sort of astounds me how shocked
people are that robert did what he did
that he took this boat and sailed it to
freedom but i sort of liken it to if you
are starving you haven't eaten in two
weeks but yet you are put in a room with
this amazing buffet in front of you
and then people leave and close the door
you know
you're gonna you know robert he he
wanted to be free he had saved money he
had tried to
buy the freedom of his wife and children
hadn't gotten that far yet and then saw
this opportunity and he took it so
tell us how we can help people
tell your friends
um but i did hear that we have time for
one more question if there was someone
waiting in the back
i just i just had a question you know um
when you're doing your research and as
you're doing your writing
we write a lot about
the men in history
did you find yourself sorry but um did
you find yourself balancing out the
women in his life and how
you know they were important
it's a great question i think sadly we
don't have a lot to go on
hannah i think had a big impact on this
trip i think she's an unsung hero of
course hannah was his uh his wife
and
you know i was determined to find an
interview with her and i looked and
looked and looked and i only found one
mention of her in one article
and it was there was a correspondent in
beaufort at the time and he happened to
interview her on the street and she
explained that they had all decided if
it looked like they were going to be
captured when they were trying to escape
that rather than going back to slavery
they would hold hands and jump overboard
with their children and drown themselves
so you know as much as i absolutely
adore robert smalls i think i'm biased
but of course as a woman but i think you
know hannah and lydia particularly his
mother um really instilled in him such a
sense of um
empowerment that i think could have very
easily been been lost to him so i wish
that there was more i could have added i
certainly was interested in the two
women who were
brought on board the ship we don't
exactly know their relationship to
smalls but i did find an article later
that said
one of the young women that was on there
he hosted once he was able to buy the
home
on prince street he hosted a wedding for
her and and he was considered he
considered her his adopted daughter
um but what history we'll never know you
know and that's that's why fiction is
sometimes appealing you can add that
the one thing that i just quickly add i
i think lydia his mother is the real
central figure in his life i don't think
robert smalls is robert smalls without
his mother
and uh robert had the somewhat rare
opportunity to grow up at least the
first 12 years with her and you know
traditionally once
children got to the point where they
could be monetized they were whisked
away and sent to work and robert got a
chance to grow up with her i mentioned
the quote um i think that speaks
to
something that she invested in there are
other examples where she
sort of
took him places to see the realities of
of slavery that he
might
have been shielded from otherwise and so
the other just
quirk of of uh of history
she when he was in charleston when the
civil war broke out
she was you know still in beaufort and
the battle of port royal november 1861
freed essentially not legally but
effectively freed her so while robert
was in charleston dreaming about freedom
i can only imagine that it worked on his
nerves that his mom was free
so i think that was another element to
this
sure thank you
all right well thank you very much for
coming appreciate it
thanks everyone for coming out um if
you're interested in buying the book you
can get it right at our register up at
the front of the store and uh lines will
start forming to the left right here if
you're interested in signing
here's a look at some of the current
best selling none
[Music]
this week on q a
journalist and author kate lineberry
she discusses her book be free or die
the amazing story of robert smalls
escape from slavery to union hero
[Music]
kate lineberry when did you first get
interested in robert smalls and who
was he
well i first learned about his story a
few years ago after my first book had
come out i was looking for another idea
and actually my youngest brother sent me
a short article he had seen on robert
smalls and i was astounded to find that
i never heard of this man
i'd done a lot of writing for the new
york times on the civil war i worked for
smithsonian magazine and wrote about the
civil war for them and i had never heard
of him so it was a little article that
encapsulated his life and i just wanted
to know more
i wanted to know how
this man who had been told from the time
he was a young child that he was not
worth anything could have had the
courage and determination to find a way
out of slavery and i just was intrigued
and i couldn't stop reading about him
born in
1839 where was he born and into what
situation he was born in beaufort south
carolina
which is about 75 miles
from charleston
it's a very small town
at the time
but it was a very wealthy town it was
founded uh with it was the wealth that
the town had was from uh slaves that had
been imported from uh west africa uh the
main crops were indigo uh cotton and
rice by the time smalls was born it was
mostly
mostly rice
and
excuse me he uh
he um
at the time
well let me and let me ask you this as
you were talking i was thinking about
who was his mother and his father
yeah his mother we don't know who his
father was his father was many people
believe he was henry mckee the owner of
smalls
his mother was lydia polite who was a
slave who was born on the plantation of
the mckee family and at the age of 10
she was 9 or 10 she was taken from the
plantation from from with the beef with
the mckee family
to help raise their children
and so
we don't know who uh robert small's
father was it doesn't look like he ever
knew in fact the name smalls comes from
um it was a name chosen by robert
himself who were the mckees the mckees
were a very wealthy family in beaufort
they were pretty much beaufort royalty
at the time
and they
were a prominent family that had the
respect of a lot of people robert was
very fortunate in the fact that henry
mckee was a very kind owner if you can
have a kind owner of course he was still
enslaved
which made it a very difficult life but
but smalls was fortunate in the fact
that he was raised as a health servant
with his mother
obviously no no in
no one who was enslaved is having a the
life that they want but compared to the
life that they would have had on the
plantation it was much more um they were
they had access to information um and
they had regular food um and and
hand-me-downs closed it was certainly
not ideal but it was far better than the
life of a plantation slave how many
brothers and sisters did they have
well we know lydia had one son um
about 20 years before robert
by the time she had robert she was in
her 40s
but he pretty much grew up as an only
child living in the house the slave
house behind the mckee house which still
exists today in beaufort it's a very
large white house that's on the historic
registry
um
yeah what's beaufort south carolina like
and i know
people make the mistake all the time
that there's a beauford north carolina
but what's it like in the now and you
say how far is it from charleston which
is on the coast yeah it's about 75 miles
it's also on the coast beaufort was very
um it's a beautiful town
very small compared to charleston
at the time
they did have a lot of slaves living in
town and then robert would have gone out
to the plantations with mckee to help
him with some of his duties so he was
seeing a lot of of uh different ways of
life let me just interrupt to point out
this map because if people are straining
to find out where uh
buford is and also charleston it's it's
right down there on the
southern southeastern point there right
and it was a very strategic part for the
place for the union army in november
1861 they actually um decided that was
where they were going to have a port
they port royal is just south of
beaufort and they captured that it was
the first capture it's the first major
union naval victory of the war
and by doing so
by this point smalls was already in
charleston he had he had been relocated
there by his owner
but in 1861 the union captured the area
and beaufort became this union
stronghold um which was
which had the
charleston citizens very concerned
because they were so close why did the
civil war start right there in
charleston
well charleston south carolina was of
course the first state to secede
and then charleston um was known as the
spiritual capital of the confederacy
so it was it wasn't as strategic of a of
a place to capture as it was a uh would
be a moral victory for the union so it
very quickly became a place where the
union wanted to capture it and they
wanted to prove um to the south that
they
they were the victor
this the war actually started on what
date do you remember
april 12
1861
and
why that's right
how much i mean how many people lived in
that part of the united states
wow it was i mean compared to the north
there were a lot fewer people living in
the south but charleston was it was a
place where a lot of in fact about
during the international slave trade
about um 60 of slaves who came into the
country came through charleston so it
was a major port in the country um and
it was like i said before a very
important
spiritual capital of the confederacy
that a lot of
a lot of goods and services came out of
charleston
and
compared to beaufort it was it was a
major city for smalls he was relocated
there by his owner when he was just 12
years old
mckee decided that he was going to move
houses and we think that lydia robert's
mother actually encouraged mckee to
allow robert to go to charleston um with
the hopes of having more options of
course he was hired out as a slave which
was a very common practice at the time
um so he was on his own to find work but
everything he earned obviously went back
to mckee
what was a slave worse then
well it depended on uh several factors
um one was your age um how muscular you
were
lots of factors went into this but i
know that when
robert eventually married a woman named
hannah and when hannah was sold
to her owner king kingman in 1847 she
and her three children were worth less
than two about two thousand
dollars hannah was how much older than
robert
she was um about 13 years older
considerably older you say that in your
book that you legally couldn't marry if
you were a slave that's right it was a
law in south carolina but they were able
to get the permission
of their owners so robert smalls had to
get the permission of henry mckee and
then he also had to go to samuel kingman
who was lydia hannah's owner and asked
permission for her so it was only
something that was allowed for trusted
slaves it was a
something that would help their morale
and it was something that they could
easily do i mean of course any slave
children that were born
would become the property of
the female slaves owner so was in their
best interest to encourage
to encourage relationships and to
encourage marriage when possible how did
you get interested in the civil war
well i've long been interested in the
civil war ever since i was very young i
have two ancestors um i grew up knowing
that two of my ancestors both fought at
gettysburg but they were on either side
of the war which was very intriguing to
me
one was 28 years old he was one of the
pennsylvania bucktails
another was just a 19 year old kid
from north carolina
and they were both injured at gettysburg
and the
confederate was actually sent to two pow
camps um so that that was intriguing to
me and then the more i read about it as
i got older and wrote pieces for uh
disunion which was the new york times
blog i just became intrigued it's such a
fascinating time in our history
i think the reverberations of the war
are clearly still being felt today
um
so i think it's an important period for
us to understand and that's truly you
know it was robert small story that
intrigued me but he's also a vehicle for
exploring the um relationships um
uh the racial relationships at the time
which i thought was was very interesting
i i thought i was fairly knowledgeable
about the subject and i learned that
there was so much more that i didn't
know what was one of the first things
you learned that you didn't know
well i didn't realize that when um any
enslaved person and i use the term
enslaved that is a preferred term by
many people because it gives the the
power back to the person they were
enslaved rather than defining them as a
slave
but for those that were
enslaved and got to their freedom i
didn't realize that they were considered
contraband so robert smalls when he
actually became
got to the union ships in his great
escape he was not actually free now most
slaves did not recognize that
necessarily
but it was an important point the u.s
government was not ready to say whether
we were going to free
all the slaves whether that was a point
of the war um
it was a a major factor and i didn't
realize how much lincoln had also um you
know he was trying to placate the border
states so much um that you know for so
long he was not sure what what he was
going to do about the slaves either
where did you grow up i grew up in
raleigh north carolina and where did you
go to school
unc chapel hill
and how this to study the civil war how
did you go about it and how often did
you go where there was a battle
um read a lot of books um did in my
research for for these writing projects
i did that but i've also certainly been
to gettysburg into other major civil war
attractions
i think going to any place um
is so important to get a feel for when
you're doing your research which is why
i spent time obviously in charleston and
beaufort as well
um
you know when you when you start seeing
the place where these people actually
walked it becomes much more real to you
um and uh
you know i think the more we can learn
about the civil war the better off we'll
all be it was it's still impacting us
today
we're going to put robert smalls
photograph on the screen and have you
tell us
some things about him how long did he
live
he lived until 1915.
he ended up becoming
a u.s congressman he served five terms
in the house of representatives
uh his career was um
it was it was difficult after he had
been accused of uh he had there was a
bribery charge against him at one point
in his career and he never fully
recovered from that and
and that's my opinion is one of the
reasons why he's not better known today
he ended up ending his career as the
customs collector in buford
but when i look at this man um i see
someone who had incredible
courage and perseverance and um
you know when he ended up he had three
well he had several children
one young boy died during the war but
his other three children that he had
throughout his life
he valued education and he made sure
that they had the best education they
could and when i see him when i look at
him i see a father who is very concerned
that his children have a better life
it's it's ultimately the reason that he
decided to take the chance that he did
in escaping on the planter
he risked everything to get his um he
had a four-year-old and a young
son at the time it was about a year
along with his wife out of slavery
what's the planter
the planter was a sidewheel steamer
about 147 feet long that
robert was working on
it was built right before the war
happened
once the war and was used as a cotton
transport ship
once the war broke out the owner of it
john ferguson started leasing it to the
confederates
for 125 a day which was a considerable
amount so when robert decided that he
was going to escape on board the ship
it was may 1862 he had been working on
the onboard it as a basically he started
as a deckhand but he worked as a as a
wheelman or a pilot they wouldn't give
the title of pilot to a slave at the
time but that's essentially what he was
doing and um
and that's where we were with the night
that he escaped in may
1862. so if you were a slave and he was
in charleston and you're walking around
how does somebody know you're a slave or
enslaved charleston had a very unique
custom in that they had slave badges
that they required all slaves to wear
they're uh usually
diamond-shaped metal badges and it was
up to the owner to
it was like a license every year they
would have to get a badge that said what
occupation they were doing and what year
it was
and so any slave that was walking around
including smalls would have had um had
to wear a badge at all times that was in
part to differentiate them from the free
black population which i didn't realize
was fairly substantial in charleston
about 3 000 free blacks at the time
how did the free blacks and the enslaved
blacks get along
well there was a lot of i think a lot of
people who were a lot of free blacks
often times tried to help their enslaved
brothers and sisters
by actually purchasing them it was
actually illegal unless the south
carolina legislature
approved it to um to free your slaves by
this point and so a lot of um free
blacks actually purchased family members
as a way to
get them out of the control of their
owner um of course there's you know it's
a very debated topic and there are lots
of
of interesting stories but there
certainly were some free blacks who
owned slaves as well
but i think
robert was part of
several secret societies when he was
there we don't know a lot of their
dealings but they were mutual aid
societies and these were some of them
were with free blacks and some of them
were made up of slaves but they tried to
help each other and so
when one person's family member died
they might all contribute for a funeral
or they might all contribute to help
you know with any kind of cost that the
family might incur that they weren't
getting
so there was some reciprocity there was
some interactions within the community
but um
for the most part i think slaves were so
controlled that they did not have a lot
of time to interact it was actually
illegal for more than a i think three or
so
african americans to meet together
without a white person present so just
for this for a moment if you were
enslaved and all of a sudden you were
sold you just take the badge off
if you were enslaved and you were sold
then two let's say you were sold to a
free freeman uh
free black what would you or it didn't
matter you all of a sudden were well
let's say if you're if you're sold to
somebody else but how if they just freed
you what would happen
well technically you weren't freed
because it was illegal so um but i it's
a great question it's an interesting
question um
i would assume that you would still have
to
follow the rules of the day and that you
couldn't you know you were still limited
because you were still a slave even
though for all intents and purposes
you were living with your family member
who had purchased you
so um
i think i think that you would still
probably be wearing a
slave badge and walking around
so when the attack came in fort sumter
in april of uh
1861 where was robert smalls on that day
so he was already working on board the
planner he was um
a deckhand at that point he had just
started working
we don't know specifically what he saw
that day
but it certainly i'm sure he saw a lot
of the white charlestonians watching
from their rooftops watching the attack
cheering it on
it was something that both sides thought
the war would end very quickly
of course that wasn't the case we had
four long years ahead of us and millions
of deaths
but
but robert also would have seen a lot of
the celebrations in the streets
fireworks going off
they wanted this battle at that point
the white charlestonians
so when did it all begin
that
robert smalls wanted to
figure out a way to get away from the
confederates
well i think he i think he was always
looking as um as he was growing older
but then once he married hannah he was
only about 17 years old when they
married they soon had children and i
think that really elevated his quest for
freedom a lot more
he just didn't want to see his children
grow up in the in the atmosphere that he
had
there were some brutal aspects very
brutal aspects to charleston
particularly there was something called
the workhouse where um
if a uh an owner did not want to punish
his slaves by himself uh he could send
them for a fee to the workhouse which
was a former sugar warehouse and so
sometimes owners would would threaten
their slaves by saying i'm gonna send
you for a little sugar
is that located right downtown in
charleston yes it no longer exists now
the building but but that was downtown
charleston and that's where um as slaves
would be punished there were some
barbaric tactics that they used there
was a treadmill i mean it was it was
pretty horrendous stuff and robert would
have seen that um growing up and so
um
yeah it was uh was he or any of his
family members sent to uh ever sent to
the workhouse we don't know um he did
talk about in 1863 he was interviewed by
the american freedmen's inquiry
commission
and he gave a lot of interesting answers
then where he talked about the brutality
he had seen on beaufort plantations
growing up
his mother who had also lydia who i
think was a very important
person in helping and creating robert as
the person that he was i think she
instilled in him determination and
courage
she had taken him to see some of the
some slaves being sold and some slaves
being punished in beaufort when he was a
child
but then through his own words to this
commission we know that he saw some
pretty brutal things on the plantations
including
he talked about seeing his aunt whipped
and
so he he saw quite a bit we don't know
if he or any of his family members were
sent to the workhouse he was actually
the only member of his family who was in
charleston so when he was sent there at
the age of 12 he was essentially on his
own um
he was under the supervision of henry
mckee's sister-in-law
but
you know just to imagine a 12-year-old
walking around the streets of charleston
trying to find work and seeing you know
people being bought and sold on the
streets and that was always his fear was
that his family would be ripped away
from him and and that was really why he
was searching so hard for a way to
escape
not just for himself
but for his family it's um it's very
difficult to it was very difficult for a
slave to run away but when you have a
child two children in tow one being a
very young child
it's nearly impossible so he really had
to find a unique way to escape and he
was looking for a long time
the ship the planner
was owned by
who john ferguson he was a local
businessman
very successful
and he leased it to the confederacy at
the time
how big was it it's about 147 feet long
how many people served on it
well there was a crew of about 10
and that included three white officers
um they were officers in the sense that
they were working on the boat but they
were not enlisted in the confederacy
um so there was a captain and then
a first mate and a deckhand
i'm sorry an engineer and then there was
the enslaved crew when did robert smalls
begin the process of trying to uh to
do something about the planner
and where was his family yes so his
family um was nearby in charleston but a
lot of slaves did not live together they
did not see each other regularly
so um but
robert started thinking about escaping
soon after a new captain came on board
the planner his name was charles realier
and he had two things that made his
robert smalls plan possible one is that
he happened to be short and stocky which
robert also was and the other was that
he favored this wearing this wide
brimmed straw hat and then a third thing
that was critical was that he often
decided to leave the ship in the
enslaved crew's hands while he and his
two other white officers went into town
to spend time with their families that
was a direct violation of confederate
orders
but he either trusted smalls and the
other men or he likely did not think
that they were capable of
taking the steamer out of charleston
harbor which was a monumental feat for
anyone but at the time even in the north
a lot of whites did not believe that
african americans were capable of such a
such a feat
um
so you had you had the the white
officers and then the
and then smalls and his crew on board so
when what was the date of the escape and
how did how did he do it so they would
had been
they had been moving guns around
charleston harbor for about two weeks
and
smalls was already thinking that
um
well he joked around with one of his
crew members that um when the crew
member put the hat of the captain on on
robert's head um he joked that he looked
a lot like the captain and that's sort
of when this light bulb went off for
smalls that hey maybe i could
impersonate this white captain between
the straw hat um stocky we leave at the
right time of day
um where it's dark enough and we get out
of the the harbor
um
and so i'm sorry what was your your
initial question no how how did it start
in other words on the day that he
decided that he wanted to escape you
know what was the setup yeah so they had
been uh moving these guns across the
harbor for the last two weeks and smalls
decided you know not only if if the
white crew leaves tonight and goes home
to be with their families not only could
we escape but we would also have guns on
board valuable guns that would be worth
everything to the union
his plan was to take the ship from the
harbor out to the union fleet which was
blockading the harbor as part of
lincoln's blockade of all southern ports
so
smalls um
alerted the men that night they had all
they had met earlier they had all agreed
to wait for his signal he was the the
mastermind behind the plan
and um and he decided that that night
once he found out the white officers
were leaving that that was the night
that he
they would make their escape and they
had been having their families come down
in preparation for this event not
knowing exactly which night would hap it
would happen but had their families
coming down to spend time with them on
board the ship so it wasn't unusual for
the family to be there and in fact
hannah robert's wife was the only woman
of the group the only family member who
actually knew that there was a plan
that they were waiting to um to put into
place
the others found out that night once the
slave curfew was about to
be instated and they kept saying we need
to get back we need to get back and
that's when smalls decided hey we need
to tell them what's happening you're not
going back we're escaping tonight were
the union
ships and the soldiers
not inside at all of uh charleston no
they were all outside the harbor
charleston harbor was
incredibly fortified by that point there
were numerous confederate fortifications
um going out through the harbor with of
course fort sumter being the final one
with its massive guns but the union
fleet was about 10 miles away from from
where small's boat was moored how often
would a ship like the planner leave and
what time of the morning
did or or the evening did he leave
columbus columbus charleston
when he was trying to escape what time
was it it was about 3 a.m um he had
gotten his the family members that
accompanied the the crew that escaped
they had gotten them to another um
boat nearby because their the planner
was actually moored right next to the
confederate general's headquarters so
not only did smalls have this incredible
opportunity to uh or
courage to take the planner but he
actually did it
when it was more next to a confederate
general's headquarters so that in itself
is astounding to me and he was what age
he was 23
had you know was not allowed to read or
write um had been enslaved his whole
life and how how did the the ship move
was it uh was it a sale it was um by
steam and so they had to um
put the fires going and get the ship
going and so there was a critical time
period they had to figure out when it
would make sense that the ship would
possibly be
operating normally and when it would be
dark enough that it would help cover
them but not too dark that it would
increase the suspicions of the
confederates so that's why he decided to
leave about three o'clock because he
wanted to hit fort sumter around four or
four thirty
when the light was just right it would
help obscure him
of course he was they had to look like
there was a white crew member on board
it would have roused suspicion
immediately if anyone had known that
this was an enslaved crew going through
the confederate harbor so when they took
off that morning they knew at any point
that if one of the centuries all along
the harbor or any of the fortifications
suspected
that smalls was or any of them were
without a white crew member they would
have immediately attacked and they
likely would have died instantly
how often did something like this happen
never it never happened
there were times when there were
as soon as the blockade of the southern
ports happened there were slaves that
swam
often rode boats mostly to get to the
union fleet they would do anything or
they
when the union was doing any
reconnaissance they would try to find
them and ask for them to bring them on
board because once they were on board
they were considered free
or at least under union control um but
just two weeks before smalls did his
incredible feat um
one of the union the confederate
general's headquarters there was a small
barge there that was taken by a few
slaves and that was a huge embarrassment
to the confederacy but amazingly enough
they didn't change any of their security
protocols after that had happened and
that event may have inspired smalls to
do what he did we don't know but he was
certainly aware of it at age 23 how much
education did he have he had no
education he had never been allowed to
read and write that was against the law
he was illiterate he was completely
illiterate
um he would have been
compared to a plantation slave he would
have been
privy to a lot more information because
he was in the house of the mckee family
listening to conversations but in terms
of education he had no he had no
education did his mother know he was
doing this
it's a great question likely not um she
was in beaufort at the time he had been
char in charleston um
very rarely got to see her that was
quite a distance to travel and
he was living his own life and so and
because lydia had been in beaufort at
the time when
the union captured port royal in that
area she was technically under union
control so she was actually free
technically a contraband but she was
free while robert was in charleston
working still as a slave so you have
charleston and below that you have
beaufort where in that
on that coast is port royal port royal
is just south of beaufort and how many i
guess union troops were there
about 14 000 landed
during that attack in november 1861 it
was led by um it was a navy attack and
it was led by admiral samuel dupont
so what was the atmosphere in the united
states in 1862 what month was it did he
escape this was in may what was the
atmosphere in the middle of the war then
well that people were realizing that
this war was not going to end quickly
at that point there had been several
large battles
the union needed a victory
they needed a port in which they could
continue to
instill this blockade they needed a way
to resupply their their um ships and
i think it was a time where anything was
possible i mean
the south could have won at that point
you know no one knew what was going to
happen and i think certainly in
confederate charleston people were just
waiting bracing themselves for an attack
i mean just 70 miles away you have 14
000 union soldiers now
and they knew what a um
what a target they were because of their
involvement in secession of course
charleston is where um the secession
ordinance was signed
and it was uh as i said earlier the
spiritual capital
so
how did he take his family with him that
night and how many other families were
allowed to get on board this
the planner yeah there were 16 people
total on board the ship um
they were not the enslaved crew there
were a few changes at the last minute
two men decided that they couldn't go
through with it
we don't know specifically why i'm
assuming that of course there was fear
of reprisal of what could happen to
their family members if even if they
made it of course they could have been
concerned with
their own lives and getting out safely
um but the first um the first mate had
his family on board
smalls had his wife and his two children
and then there were two other women that
we don't quite know their relationship
they were likely friends or family
members of other crew members
we do know that years later smalls
hosted a wedding for um for one of those
young women and um said considered her
an adopted daughter
but it was it was 16 people on board
that ship that night
how did they
get to the union ships out there
so they um they had the family members
and a few crew hidden at a wharf that
was behind them so they started at
southern wharf backtracked which would
have created suspicion and in fact there
were a couple of confederate guards who
noticed
smalls leaving the boat and one actually
watched them but he didn't report it he
just thought they were going about their
business so there was a lot of luck with
them on this whole journey
but they backtracked to pick up their
family members and then they took um
took their time they had to go slowly
they couldn't be in a hurry to arouse
suspicion and they passed
all the different forts they went to
fort near fort johnson first
waited to see if there was any
commotion or anybody sensing anything
were relieved when there wasn't and then
they finally got to fort sumter
that's when
they had to know the right codes to say
but smalls had done enough
reconnaissance trips out into the
outside of the harbor that he knew the
proper code and did it and waited
patiently to see if they were going to
attack or not
the confederates were not aware of what
was going on until
smalls turned towards the union fleet
instead of going the way he normally
would have that's when the alarm bells
went off and they
sent word um
to another close by fort to fire but
they were smalls and his uh family and
other crew members were too far away at
that point to be to be hit so they were
never fired on
they were um we we don't know for sure i
believe that they attempted to fire on
them um they were certainly not hit they
were too far away i don't know if the
confederates actually fired on them but
they were given they attempted to so you
he's on board the planner he's got 16
people on there
they've come past fort sumter when do
they when are they seen by the union
side and how do they tell the union side
that they i mean they see a confederate
ship coming to him
why did they not fire on him right
smalls was actually more worried about
this stage of the journey than he was
about getting through the confederate
harbor um because of course he was in a
confederate ship um going straight
towards a union fleet and they would
have assumed that they were attacking
them in some way
so he devised
to have a white bed sheet on board and
immediately as soon as they passed fort
sumter they lowered the confederate flag
and the south carolina flag and hoisted
a bed sheet um was it light yet
it was just getting light which was part
of his plan he wanted to be seen but
there was fog that night that was
hindering them
so they weren't sure it was a huge risk
and in fact we know from the union
records that the captain of the onward
which was the ship that was closest to
them had the guns ready and was
preparing to fire
and at the last second he saw the white
sheet and said stop
um
it was a very close call and there was
another close call once uh once they
actually got towards the ship
i think smalls and the crew were so
rattled that they weren't listening to
what the union members were telling them
and they were telling them to go a
different way than they were in
approaching the ship and once again the
captain said stop roll blow you out of
the water
and that jolted them to attention and
got them
reacting appropriately but it must have
just been a an incredible few moments at
any second they could have lost
everything so what happened to uh smalls
and the family once they were in union
hands what happened to the planter
well and as soon as smalls got
got to the union ship he was immediately
taken to samuel dupont who was in charge
of the whole south atlantic blockading
blockading squad and he um
said i need this cat i need this guy
he's valuable he's a great pilot we need
him and so he actually made smalls a
civilian boat pilot for the union and he
did that because if he had enlisted
smalls
african-americans particularly former
slaves were only allowed at that point
in the war to be classified as a boy
which was the lowest classification so
we think that the other crew members
were enlisted as boys but smalls was not
enlisted he became a civilian boat pilot
and immediately started working for
the union but
word got out in the north immediately
and he was considered a hero almost
overnight
suddenly harper's weekly and all these
other publications were um were touting
him as the hero and because he was the
mastermind behind the plan he was really
given the
the major kudos and he he um
above the other men they were included
in the story but it was definitely
smalls who was elevated to um to hero
stature where did they live then
well they ended up staying in the area
and um
working for the union in from port royal
but smalls was given an incredible
opportunity that he embraced as he
embraced all the opportunities he was
given
to speak on behalf of
the port royal experiment which was
something that was going on
after
beaufort and port royal was captured the
whites fled which is not something that
the union had anticipated um ten
thousand slaves were left behind and
were now in the care of the government
the union army which was already running
low on food
they needed help and so um they were the
port royal people were already asking
for donations in the north but um a
reverend french got the idea that smalls
would make a great example as a
as a speaker he could go around the
north and talk to people and help raise
awareness and money and that's what he
did spent a few months doing
and in the course of that he was sent to
washington where he met with abraham
lincoln and several members of his
cabinet
and actually brought back the first
orders authorizing a black regiment
from the secretary of war
uh to to beaufort how many blacks in the
both in the union and the confederacy
were actually fighting during the civil
war
believe there were about 180 000 um
so it was you know at this point they
had not been allowed the um the navy had
always allowed blacks to enlist the army
had not in the north only
yes yes
um
now that is something i certainly think
there's some debate on whether um there
were blacks fighting for the confederacy
but in general that you know it was
mostly uh northern blacks
um
and so yeah smalls by uh bringing this
authorization you know it started an
enormous um swell of people enlisting um
frederick douglass was out there
encouraging people to enlist he had sons
who enlisted um it was critical the the
role that african americans ended up
playing in the war was critical to the
union what tripped it for the union to
allow blacks
to
come into the service
i think it was part necessity
part there were enough people out there
you know it was
people pushing for a long time for this
to happen but um
the union also started seeing that the
south had an advantage because they had
slave labor and so when the war first
started they had slaves were building
fortifications they were doing lots of
work they were giving the south an
advantage and
and one of the things that smalls did
through his heroic act was he convinced
a lot of people in the north that
african americans were willing to fight
for their freedom
it's hard to imagine but at that point a
lot of people questioned whether they
would
and that's one of the major
contributions of smalls is that he
became this
focal point for people to see that
african americans were willing to do
whatever for their freedom to take any
chance and they would fight for the
union so i think it was it was a
combination of a lot of things but i
think certainly small's role was was
definitely important in
in changing that so when you began to
research uh for this book where'd you go
national archives great resource um
smalls for years fought for his pension
um because he was not enlisted um of
course he was not enlisted because he
would not have been allowed to be a
pilot at the time but he certainly
served as a member of the union
and should have been
given a
pension for that so he fought for years
so his pension records were very helpful
um at the archives also of course going
to charleston and beaufort i'm going to
some of their archives the state
archives in colombia
talking to a lot of experts
um
you know it's always good to cast a wide
net and see what you can find
there's a man named michael moore
who is the great great grandson of
robert smalls
and here he is doing a ted talk back in
2015.
this is a picture of his house
with the money one of the main things
that he did with his reward money is he
actually bought the house that his
master had
so he bought the big house and so i
always
yeah exactly there's there's great
poetry and you know a former slave going
and buying the big house
that i always agree to but but what also
was i think particularly special after
the war his former master had died
and his former master's wife
who at the time was mentally and
physically ill
came back to the house thinking that it
was still
her house and that she was still
you know the the the woman of the house
and robert embraced her and brought her
in and cared for her through her
remaining days he even allowed her to
sort of stay in the master bedroom where
she had always lived thinking that she
was still the woman of the house
do you have any idea why
robert smalls did that for mrs mcgee
robert smalls was an incredibly
forgiving uh man and he was um a
brilliant man and he um
would always surprise people and so you
know this is one of these um stories
that you know michael bulwarmor and his
mother helen bullermore have been so
incredibly supportive of my project with
this book
but it's interesting when you hear
stories from the family and then you go
and try to verify of course whenever you
possibly can
this is a story i had heard several
times about smalls bringing the family
to his home
the best documentation i could find for
it was one of the missionaries who had
come from the north to help the former
slaves in in port royal
wrote about it and she said that robert
had in the 1870s paid for their uh the
mckee family's
rail fair to charleston and allowed them
to stay in the home
the story that you'll hear on the
carriage rides through buford a lot of
times is that she lived there for the
rest of her life my understanding from
laura townes diary is that it was for a
short amount of time the family came
it's still extraordinary that robert
smalls would allow
the family to come back to the home
where he had once been enslaved he
helped pay for their he paid for their
trip to the house
and he ended up when the family refused
to eat with him he
ended up serving them separately in
their own table so
um
he was just a remarkable man i don't
know too many people who would have done
that now um some people you know say
whether well was he a mckee family
member you know the robert's father is
not known
um i tend to think
smalls was not mckee's child only
because
lydia his mother was already was raising
henry mckee for so long
but regardless of that smalls was an
incredibly warm caring person who wanted
to help people and he did not let
what he had been through during the war
stop him from helping the mckee family
he ended up i think helping
one of the the mckees sons get into
college and
he did some extraordinary things
the uh michael moore runs the the
international african-american museum in
charleston yes what's it like
uh well it has it's being built right
now so um they're raising funds for it
but it sounds phenomenal
and he's the perfect person to lead it
and i recently met with him and asked
him what is it like to walk through
these streets of charleston
knowing that your great great
grandfather was enslaved in this city
and you know it's surreal for him at
many times but it's it's such an honor i
think to um
keep small's memory alive i mean he
michael and his mother have done a great
job of preserving small's legacy uh his
mother created a traveling exhibit
they
are very uh concerned with with
protecting small's name and reputation
and getting getting his story out there
the chair of the university of texas uh
history department back in 2012 was
marvin delaney here he is talking about
another period right after the civil war
and i want you to expound on this
the general
consensus in in 1909 early 20th century
in fact almost up up to the 1960s was
that reconstruction was one of the worst
periods
in the history of this country
that reconstruction was characterized by
corrupt
carpetbaggers
and scallywags
and ignorant negroes
who misruled the south
the
so-called ignorant negroes who had
served in the governments in the south
during this period had made three very
important contributions
they had brought about the first
democratic governments in the south
they had established the first free
public schools
and they had passed new social
legislation
and as many of you know robert smalls
did all three of those things
what was reconstruction and how long did
it last
well a lot of people don't realize that
reconstruction sort of began with the
port royal experiment which was the
efforts to help these 10 000 abandoned
slaves
in in port royal and the beaufort area
because reconstruction was
the country trying to rebuild itself
after the war
and
having to incorporate
slaves into the our our whole world as
free people i mean these were people who
were kept from
any education they had never been
allowed to care for themselves and
suddenly they were free and what does
that mean
so um you know buford
is really in many ways the heart of
reconstruction um because this is where
the port royal experiment happened um
and then of course after the war robert
moved back to beaufort um
and really ended up finding a voice in
politics and um and uh it was at a time
when a lot of um
blacks were being uh voted into
political power and he was he took
advantage of that and um
ended up doing a lot i mean he actually
helped set up the first free and
compulsory education system in south
carolina um so it was a time of
rebuilding it was the time where we were
trying to
figure out how we were going to move
forward after the legacy of slavery
which of course we're still trying to do
today did he ever get any education
yes education was huge for robert small
so during the war um he went to
philadelphia for several months while it
was the planner was being refurbished he
was charged with going up there and and
seeing to um watching over the
refurbishment and during that time he
took advantage of the extra time he had
and hired a tutor
um then it's it's thought that
throughout his life he actually worked
with other tutors so he was doing the
best to educate himself and then as his
children grew up he sent them to the
best schools that he possibly could
in fact when his daughter elizabeth who
was on board the planner when he escaped
when she was 13 years old she read
the declaration of independence at a
fourth of july celebration in beaufort
and to the audience was mostly former
slaves
and it was a huge moment because for
them they saw that
this was an opportunity
their children were now going to learn
to read and write their children were
going to be educated they had features
that they never could have imagined
before so education was wasn't critical
to robert smalls
life you said that he was five terms in
the u.s house of representatives a
member of the republican party at the
time what's the bribery story
well uh smalls was elected in 1875 to
his first term in the house of
representatives and two years later
he was accused of
of taking funds while in a state
legislative role
it was i think it was a time
it was a time when people were scared
scared of blacks having more power there
was a lot going on and i think this was
the charges were an attempt to
to ruin his credibility
he was eventually pardoned but it was
not before he was sentenced to three
years hard labor and his conviction was
basically um based on a felon's
testimony did he serve for the hard
labor for three years no he served three
days in jail but was
pardoned uh in part because the south
carolina governor created a deal
that robert smalls wanted no part of he
actually
wanted the court case to go to the
supreme court where he could have his
say and prove his name prove his
innocence
but was never given that opportunity
because a deal was made in order to
i think free some
i think it was some red shirts which
were the name for these very um
white
racist fanatics in the south at the time
at the time
there were a number of blacks elected as
republicans from the south in
reconstruction when did that all end
when did when did
when did reconstruction fall apart
it's a very good question um
it's not my area of expertise um
but um i would say that you know we saw
the height of the power in the 1870s
1880s and then after that it it started
changing one of the things that i found
so shocking in my research is i did not
understand that the lengths that that
the southern states had gone to all to
reinstate slavery and all but name after
the war um so there was a lot of
violence going on small certainly
faced numerous death threats throughout
his political career
he had a unique position in the fact
that he was because his mother had grown
up on a plantation and spoke gullah
which was the local
language of
all the slaves from west africa had to
have a language that they all understood
and this became gullah
he could talk with a lot of the former
slaves in south carolina and he could
talk to the whites who were trying to
regain their power
so he acted often as a bridge between
the white and black communities but it
was it was a it was a tough road and as
we saw you know with the
jim crow laws and everything else we we
had a lot of backsliding
stephen weiss curator uh at parris
islands museum uh
somebody you i know interviewed for your
book and also he has written about it
but here he is talking about robert
smalls
uh two individuals that are associated
with the sea islands around port royal
robert smalls obviously a native another
individual who comes down and is at penn
center to help plan his strategy in the
1960s
both are very articulate both are very
well known for their speeches if nothing
else at least a lot of robert smalls of
speeches are written down and they're
wonderful things he has wonderful sense
of humor and the 1895 convention and
such when he
makes
comments back at pittsford ben tillman
and others as well
both are extremely brave
robert smalls never went around armed
after the civil war there were threats
against him he once commented uh when
you face down an eight-inch confederate
cannon these little pistols mean nothing
to you
and both were pacifists
how did stephen wise fit in all this
stephen weiss is the most knowledgeable
person about the civil war charleston
beaufort area that you'll ever meet he
and larry rowland wrote a three-volume
history of beaufort
which is fascinating and has everything
you could ever want to know about the
area in it
but steve uh was a great resource he and
larry
read the manuscript over gave insights
gave feedback pointed me to
the right people to talk to
incredibly helpful throughout the whole
process whatever happened to the planter
well
yeah unfortunately in the 1870s she
ended up sinking long after smalls had
said goodbye to her
after the war when steamers weren't
needed as much
the union actually put her up for
auction
and interestingly enough
ferguson who was the original owner
wanted the planner back he was
determined to have it i think it was
symbolic to him in some way and he was a
southerner he was a southerner
and he
he tried to get it back the first time
the boat went up for auction but he the
government figured out who he was and
that he had leased the ship to the
confederates and they turned him down
but we think that he actually had
someone else broker the deal for him
when the ship went up for auction in
baltimore a few months later
so
in 1866
ferguson had the ship back 1866 1867
and then about 10 years later
the ship was trying to tow another ship
and she sank
and
parts of the planner were salvaged at
the time but she was obviously no longer
in operation
and smalls was said to have said when he
learned
that it was like losing a member of his
family
speaking of family what happened to his
wife hannah how long did she live and
she was 13 years older than he was right
right and unfortunately hannah died
fairly young
and they had of course two children that
lived they had a third a young son who
died during the war
but a few years later i think about
seven years later smalls married another
woman a schoolteacher from charleston
annie wigg and he had a son with her as
well
so he had two wives i think hannah often
is overlooked as a hero in the story
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
records on hannah
i could only find one
newspaper source that actually recorded
anything from hannah and she was talking
about how they had agreed if it looked
like they were going to be captured when
when if they were attacked when they
were escaping that they would all hold
hands and jump overboard and drown
rather than be
recaptured and taken back to slavery
you say that
mr smalls died when he was 75 what was
the rest of his life like after being in
the united states congress
and uh what was the impact of the
bribery accusation
yeah i don't think he ever fully
recovered from that
accusation uh he ended up being
re-elected
but he it was never quite the same he
ended up becoming a customs collector in
beaufort and spent many spent many years
doing that but i think he really wanted
to be back in d.c
making change making people's lives
better
but unfortunately that was not the case
but he had a nice life he um of course
as we saw from the video earlier he
ended up being able to buy the home that
he had once been enslaved in and that
was so important to him and he you know
one of my favorite quotes of his is um
something about how he was so happy to
be able to sen to give that to leave
that house for his children and his
family what did he die of
uh diet complications from diabetes and
where is he buried he's buried in
beaufort at the tabernacle church which
he was a member of in the last years of
his life they have a nice statue there
and he's buried beside his two wives and
one of his daughters
in your opinion has the united states
paid enough
honor to him for what he did i don't
think so i think there's a recognition
that's starting to happen
about his contributions in in charleston
there are two markers now historic
markers
in downtown charleston that talk about
the planter and marks robert smalls
contributions
but i think with this renewed interest
in reconstruction um
you know there are several places in
beaufort that are not part of a
reconstruction monument now
um there's more of a i think
charlestonians in general and the whole
country is embracing more of its
african-american history and in doing
that i think robert smalls will get the
recognition that he deserves
the name of the book is be free or die
the amazing story of robert smalls
escape from slavery to union hero
and our guest kate lineberry thank you
very much for joining us thank you so
much
[Music]
do
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org q a programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]
if you enjoyed this week's q a interview
with kate lineberry here are some other
programs you might like author clarence
lussane talks about his book the black
history of the white house history
professor edna mefford on the life and
career of abraham lincoln and historian
ronald white discusses his biography of
president grant titled american ulysses
you can watch these anytime or search
our entire video library at cspan.org
c-span's washington journal